c'est normal en fait vous expliquer ça
vas-y ils ont commencé en avance ouais
c'est bien bravo en gagne deux minutes
c'est bien ce serait beau qui commet ce
genre commence à 13h48 aujourd'hui
du coup on suit alireza c'est à ces
leçons là j'ai
par contre très beau qui est pas la
caméra
ainsi comme quoi c'est ça devait être
alireza jusqu'au bout fab
je vais juste vous faire marcher et
après on sera tranquille vous avez tout
marche est on prêt
on a les caméras on a tout le monde crie
corps et à quelle table
et on affirme déjà contre ding
dong est qu il ya eu ces quatre là j'ai
trois cas les six pieds deux pouces et 5
des 3rocs en fait c'est un dragon à
l'envers voilà un wagon à l'heure où on
les vend pas encore fait des cinq
et on devait pas y avait du tout mais
c'est un bon système se faisait cinq
mois d'être le seul
on sait genre aux coûts du numéro trois
attentats est en train de mettre le bon
numéro deux parties parce que ça c'est
vrai que c'est écrit c'est basé aussi
ouais ça ouais bah là dessus on a
beaucoup de choses qui gênent et a
beaucoup changé
de prix du poids sur cette base et
parfois il a un beau bild
annonce à gênés vous que vous faites
désolé
ouais non je disais au troisième coup
après j'ai trois questions g2
évidemment un art peut jouer des cinq
qu'on a souvent vu un d'ailleurs sardo
si c'est l'inversé
et en fait l'intérêt de l'ordre de coude
dingli rennes donc de jouer que j'ai 3
et fouché dexter départ séquestrois trop
vite c'est des idées de carantec foulée
donc voilà c'est une différence après
par contre tu te lire plus facilement
les c6
[Musique]
pas sûr mais ces six manches avec des 5
il est visé c'est l'idée mais c'est
magnifique en fait mais c'est moi je
conduis pour ça tout seul mais
j'ai passé quand je vais remonter
j'avais pas foncer
sur place ces gens remarquer je t'aide
pana c'est pour les connaisseurs sa
transe au sol dans une catalane à un
genre de catalan mais pas vraiment à
46,3
ouais faut allier deux puissent pousser
les pions et d4 et d5 met donc voilà ça
va plus être une sorte de 6,6 à
l'inversé
bon le plan des blancs se veut être de
faire ou trois des quatre à jour
beaucoup
ou toujours avec dams et de tourbe et un
à trois des quatre par là bas on va voir
qu'on ding compte jouer mais c'est une
ouverture de combat se donnent des
parties intéressantes
après ce que pour ali reza s'il termine
est vraiment mal le tournoi ça pourrait
être dur psychologiquement pour la suite
pas plus qu'aujourd'hui
c'est déjà demain si saad est dur c'est
déjà dur ou un objet intime agit du fini
à trois et demi sur 14 un truc comme ça
au 4 sur 14 est ce que pour la suite de
sa carrière ça peut lui mettre un vrai
coup au moral
non mais tu reviens va en fait on se
disait ça pour dépôt s'il va rejouer
après luis figo puis voilà
puis qu'on joue aux échecs on perd des
parties des fois des parties importantes
en défendent espérant gagner et puis la
fois apprendre à vivre les défaites et
revenir à tirer les leçons et voilà
ok on peut juste à les jeter en est
quand même aux parties intéressantes de
la journée j'ai envie de dire
caruana à son âge à boeufs à 6 au
troisième réputé comme mauvais pour
plusieurs raisons fait un mauvais
douteux ouais bon pourquoi pas
intéressant en fait l'idée principale
d'assister que des quatre
s'établir à yanis et 3,5 il n'y a pas de
calais b 5 du coût donc lequel il va
faire ça va drouille où il veut et f5 ya
des cinq qui joue sur la surcharge du
pur mais silva ailleurs il n'y a pas
foule et cinq échecs c'est aussi
l'utilité de la 6 1 ouais silva ailleurs
genre b3 b4 et puis puis des 5 qui
arrive c'est une nage dans s'améliorer
où on n'a pas dû jouer des six cds 5 ans
fait tout bêtement du coup en fait
les coûts réputé pour les blancs contre
à 6 c soit faire ces trois une alpine où
tu te dis ah si ce n'est peut-être pas
le coup de l'année après comme la lapine
c'est un peu lent bombe alors qu'ils
font des saints qui joue c'est des dames
devant et c'est ce genre de choses bon
il joue normalement avec les filles ceci
ce qui est possible ou alors l'autre
manière de jouer c'est de faire ces
quatre sur 1,6
et au de maroussi et après tu fais chier
ces trois des quatre
donc voilà à voir ce que fait briller en
tête après il avait même une dernière
option se faire cueillir ces trois parce
qu'a priori les noirs vont bien jouer un
coup
d si ceux-ci sais pas quoi et après tu
fais des
4es jarbou fait une sorte de kiev 6
nageurs donc payer ces trois peut-être
le seul couac pseudo indépendance serait
de faire b5 mais bon tu peux quand même
faire des quatre et ça ressemble c'est
normal
alors il ya encore un coup
sûr à six il y avait quatre
noms mais comme ça en vrai ça je serais
étonné qu'ils fassent mais c'est vrai
que vu qui en a qui nous sort des six
aurait d'autres couples normaux et que
c'est pas complètement que même sur des
six c'est pas
ça pourrait jouer sa retraite
il le jouera pas mais à
nos fatwas
mais en fait c'est un coup
franc en grande cam un regard 10.21
d'autres chaises dans la gueule
mais ça fait mal là bas nous en 16 ans
tondo chess dans la gueule
c'est beau ça
a du coup c'est pas mal que
surprise de rajab a faim on s'attendait
à 4,5 une sorte de berlinoises deviendra
un peu souffrir ou quoi et la famille du
coup il peut pas jouer ça ce qui est
préparé un don cassis évident il connaît
en fait un gr ce n'est pas une surprise
at jamais jusqu'où qu'est ce que c'est
mais il doit se demander qu'est ce que
radjabov en tête et quel schéma il veut
pas ce que vous avez vu je voulais c3 c4
ce papa ricky et c3 c3 gros type de
position différents
tu vas me faire j'ai trois peut-être des
coûts bizarre mais bien normalement
c'est les 3 dont j'ai parfois
écrit 4 tu minimise b4 c'est incroyable
le minimisent b4 mais qui sait alors si
la b4 bravo
je
t'offre un truc mais parce que cet
accueil mines gecamines peut-être une
petite dizaine de minutes les actus
minimise vraiment le coup alors que
l'aca emon williams à mon avis voilà
philippe bécade tempo 1 c'est très
possible je pense pas qu'il réfléchisse
très longtemps
même les autres ils font quoi et même à
3 d'ailleurs ouais
ça serait pas complètement stupide et
même qui a rallié à 3
hockey à 3 chez pas un peu peur de ce
coup
là si c'est pas débile
non mais puis on a trois pareil mais
pion à 3
alors qu'avec moins de palliser des
quatre mois en fait c'est un grand bi
1,7 donné le pion b ont dévié le pion c
est prendre le centre c'est en fait de
pioncer 5 des siennes vient pour
échanger le centre des blancs voilà
après évidemment c'est un grand vide
donc ça coûte un pion
métal centre tu vois un développement
facile de faire food étroite schwarzy
rock tpir cendres peuvent être plus ou
moins mobiles etc etc
non c'est jouable et à 3 en fait c'est
pour préparer b400 donnait bien et sur
qui sait si tu peux quand même faire bkc
avec l'idée surprise crise qui a rallié
prend battue va faire des quatre
maintenant et tu feras c3 et tu
toucheras lecavalier tu voudras 5 et en
vrai c'est pas clair mais genre à trois
c'est réellement enfin complètement
premier degré un coût possible il a fait
quoi ces quatre c4 est passé le coup je
jouais à vous voulez faire b4y se
trouvait
la partie à côté oui non mais ces quatre
très bien même si c'est censé être le
coût principal
donc pour jouer des mains d'emma roxy
contre la sicilienne
après il y avait une manière de
d'essayer avec les noirs de ne pas
rentrer là-dedans un coup stratégique
c'est de faire des six des 4 6 4 mais
c'est pas très bon des français pour
prendre 3 est en fait tu perds je les
prends pas ce que dame prend
des français est vite qu'ici six cases
noires ça va enfin pourquoi pas mais en
fait j'ai pensé assez fort vous pouvez
la structure met échange les dames du
déroc à la paire de fouet ces paraphes
ses pions doublette uva pour avancer et
vrai bon les blancs sont bien trop
davantage vraiment mais si les gens
connaissent pas ce petit truc tu peux
tricks et un nul à fêter ses 6 bonbons
que des 4 ou qu'elle sait trop mais je
dirais des quatre parce que qu'est c3 il
va te faire en fait les normes la sauce
inquiet
pour faire un truc symétrique éviter des
donc
en ce moment
après la mauvaise nouvelle pour fall ian
ritchie sait qu'il a plus b 4
normalement là c'est vraiment doute pas
à cause de fillon prend qui avait là ça
ce serait vraiment bien fait ça c'est
vraiment gros avantage version améliorée
de tout ça c'est vraiment terrible mecar
ailier prendrait
dans la deuxième course sans prendre le
centre
normalement des quatre surclassée 6
ha ok on peut continuer à avoir des
tours m à lausanne accueille ses
costumes sont là en fait c'est une
partie marrant parce que si un des deux
gagnent une somme il se remet quand même
pas plus d'un quart d'heure parce qu'il
a un demi point d'avancé oui oui c'est
vrai que daiwa donc en fait signe à
gagnac les noirs y semer un peu dans la
course même pas mal duda il reviendra je
mène c'est un peu long
ok et ckoi a aussi remporté deux
fois le pétrole
n'a qu'a donc ça doit être la caméra de
ouais on voit un dépôt qui a beaucoup de
présence sur l'échiquier il est un peu
plus assis que pour son match contre
contre carl cen
sad a encore les dépôts qui a joué une
autre petrov va sur food & cie se fout
des 3 en sixième il avait joué et qui
essaient 6 contre nac away et là il est
revenu à s'en fout des six
je crois que ce qui devait un peu contre
carl scène et
je sais pas exactement mais il a l'air
d'être dans sa prépa me dois de
reconnaître est
bon ici j'imagine faut tenter de me
prend b71 actually ou 4 et enfin il se
lève tôt les femmes on va simplement
essayer de le voir voilà voilà on voit
passer à temps hop hop on le suit à la
trace est pour n'a pas les caméras du
vestiaire sage ouais mais t'as vu c'est
également un joli geste technique côté
régis attaque
et du coup quand il revient tac tac tac
en cascade
ouais donc m 1
il ya famille qui joue le jeu des cats
je crois ouais je pense voir les trois
puntos
ouais c'était c'était magnifique on a
suivi le bide
normalement a dit va faire c'est prendre
bon c'est pas beau c'est sûr qu'on a des
crampes mais bon on se fie dépôt on
attend qu'il repasse enfin un nom alors
voilà c'était une intéressant c'était
digne je crois
je ne veux pas la mêlée quoi ouais non
ça
ne te suis pas
message ou un côté famille
voilà c'est quoi le coude rajhi
c'est quoi ce on y ressent aussi fait
que ie6 ou des trucs comme ça
[Musique]
à 2,5 me questionner mais du coup ça
c'est peut-être hyper intéressant c'est
du rarement vu mais donc je pense qu'à y
avait cinq soit normal
c'est peut-être malin comme prépa voilà
quoi il a - ou moins de rajhi -
faute enfin je pense le kf5 est normal
parce qu'eux on avez vu tout à l'heure
que le problème était dessin qui vont là
c'est plus un problème mais
en
fait il joue sa structure qui jouait
dans sa jeunesse de kalach slash
schennikov
[Musique]
des power passé on l'a raté mais ok ça
peut vraiment être intéressant peut-être
si oui mais bon en fait je ne peux pas
trop me dire encore mais ça peut être
une manière intéressante avec les noirs
parce que pour tous les joueurs du genre
de position tu évites tout ce qui est
rond sur limoux et cetera tata structure
était vide plein de choses et tu force
un peu les bons entraînements en fait
donc ses quatre principales donc ouais
mais bon c'est plus intéressant et ça ça
je crois que c'est une ligne en force ce
n'est pas non c'est pas fou des six d'un
point à sept fous h3 je crois faut
connaître j'ai h dames 5
ça a l'air d'être un trop fort ça tapait
fiat ou 6,5 et voitures flashées que sa
case blanche est une langue est la dame
de fer quand tu te barres de toit ouais
faut connaître sa l'abattre ordi un bon
des fois fait foi soir venu on peut
suivre les cours de sa va faire nul en
force ou le rose bar & mail a tellement
l'air confiant le dépôt que normalement
il connaît tout bah oui mais il connaît
tout mais ça a l'air sympa en fait juste
on va se mettre côté noir parce que
c'est marrant il à quoi d'avoir une
tournette demont après x 3
et faut prendre f3 je pense que tu es
matin
j'illustre 1 st pal appartient aux vrais
bons ces théories 15 ses bas ses comptes
mais c'est joli il faut prendre ou des
six noms fou qu'ont ces dames jce adam g
6e 3 h 20 la meute 4 oui mais c'est
beaucoup plus simple f3 dam des trois
ça fait notre force les des deux
frères
vont connaître des coûts
as tu connais tout gagné tout
et tu vas récupérer la dame en fait
quant au prince est pas mal tu veux
dédier
une brosse à dents le français 6 demain
roger deux
dames de ranger un
jeu serait pas complètement sûr qu'ils
aient perpétré en europe après si tu
sais tu c1 aurait fait
que katia dame prend f3
et même pas permettre en fait durant
cette finale
non mais après la fin le langage
corporel et les coûts envoyé tempo et
ses abbayes connais par coeur
ça c'était une prépa pour le match pour
magasin ça c'est résister pour magnus
est là rapporte mais là quand on parle
de la chance pas de chance d'accord
c'est balle perdue mais bon mais s'est
jamais complètement perdu parce que en
fait quand à travailler tu mérites 1 et
puis ces balles perdues à laquelle tu
peux t'attendre gérés par des balles
perdues la presse par un truc contre
quelqu'un mais c'était impossible de
savoir la wii la petrov
oui enfin tu sais que
tu sais enfin c'est pas une vraie balle
perdue tu t'imagines cas des balles qui
très près c'est ça c'est bon elle est
perdue mais tu le sais tu l'as trouvé en
fait ses parents une balle perdue c'est
une balle trouvée voilà peut-être fait
roi chain d'avocats après oui on va être
heureux nous on a peut-être fait un
petit trois camps au
centre d'alger ces chèques et de se
lever et le seul pouce et rachat à yaffo
g5 aussi mais là dessus permettre dé
même merde être ça vient de finale quoi
et c'est voté en ag si je me lève
non mais en fait c'est idéal pour des
pauses il annule en poche ces six
rapports de faire le fou ça peut même
menacer projet doit bien connaître et en
plus moi je pense qu on taira pas il a à
50% richard on est d'accord je pense tu
dois pas faire le dingue un bar en bas
afin avant la partie tombé de gagner
mais là bas ça se passe comme ça
méné peau quand même c'est non c'est bon
il s'est pris un hameçon à la gueule qui
n'était pas destiné c'est ça on peut
dire un hameçon qui traînait m'ont élu
merde
bon ben c'est grosse prépa
erding farrugia qui est parti
encore une fois bien préparés alireza
il a tous les thèmes peau ouais fait
avoir par mehmet akif 3 des 6 rue
du hâ 5 des 4
en fait on va dire je restructure je
préfère toujours les blancs mais le pion
à bien jouer ces dynamiques armes ici on
peut pas faire cas il prend à 4,1 il en
l'air mais faut prendre des quatre ont
pas une pièce
donc tout pion à bien gagner de l'espace
ça peut donner à casa 5 à la dame il
faut toujours compter sur un petit coup
à trois moments qui vient t'embêter
voilà mais dans l'autre sens aussi
d'ailleurs dans l'autre sens le truc
c'est dû coûter pions perte de la
mobilité mais ça devait saféris
fait ces genres position moi j'ai
l'habitude de voir que le fond j'ai
satin
et lahonce et 5 qui est pas trop mal
bon il connaît bien plus ali reza qui
dans sa prépa
intéressant alors qu'on ding réagi je
suis en train de me dire un truc sur sur
riesch a sur les peaux way qui est
peut-être pas qu'on en fait fait est que
des pauses quelqu'un de très pragmatique
et est intelligent et peut-être qu'en
fait il a pris tout son fric pour ses
frais pas fâché il a dû prendre des
millions
si du monde fait sûrement perdre contre
carl scène je me prends pas trop la tête
mais en fait je reviens pas encore comme
ça je regagne les candidats jeu reprend
2,3 millions tu vois ce que je veux dire
ouais bon après tout le truc c'est que
tu peux pas être sur 10 des candidats
maintenant que je réparais de moulins
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
qu'ils vont car le cng 5 10% de chances
de gagner mais si je perds je me prends
pas la tête je
tu vois je laisse filer le match dont je
m'en fous je garde mes trucs et je
reviendrai fort aux candidats est en
fait mon objectif n'est pas de battre
carlson avec cette prépa c'est de
revenir et de le rejouer quoi je
referais bien des antilles marshall
ouais c'est ça j'ai absolument rien à
[ __ ] je ne te montre absolument un peu
dommage ce match ne m'intéresse pas je
prends le fric à fond je
regarde les candidats regarde je
reprends du fric
et c'est que c'est pas con way mais
quand je dis un truc c'est que faut être
sacrément confiant pour penser que tu
viendras les candidats choisis mais d'un
autre côté tu as tellement aucune chance
de battre car c'est mon petit fils dit
je suis dit ma stratégie beaucoup plus
intelligente
ne prépare pas contre toi moi pour les
candidats pendant six mois plus tard
regarde dormir actes notamment world for
me battre que tu rates tu me laisses le
titre ice et ça ça le regarde ce voyage
a battu c'est facile pour toi tu avais
diffus va faire 2009 plus tôt ouais
ce serait beau et c'est bien d'écrire sa
légende que le premier jour a gagné 3,4
fois les candidats d'affilée tout en la
justice prend le free qui fait que des
prépas non mais sans rire en a gagné
deux fois les conduire d'affilée c'est
quasiment du jamais vu je pensais
spassky qui a fait
mais je sais même pas s'il ya quelqu'un
d'autre
ah non deux fois d'affilée c'est dur et
pernod tite et gagner à hua hin en
d'aussi et il y en a eu d'autres
oui car porsche sur l'isla of may
d'affilée
je suis pas sûr peut-être trois ou
mischa pour
karpov
kampala fils émile a gagné après
peut-être à venir
mais à mes d'affilée noir et ça se
trouve il a fait des candidats karpov
mais peut-être 87,90
euros 10 buts c'est en fait il ya le
match 84 pas finie l'image de 85 qui
paie real match revanche de 86 après
j'imagine doit se qualifier ouais et
donc les candidats de 87 où il joue
contre andry stocco la malice qualifie
et là il se qualifie et pour 90 6
qualifiés aussi bon gars pas ça fait
deux fois oui cela fait deux fois
l'espace y aura nantes a fait deux fois
mais pas d'affilée 1,95 2007 et un petit
diable de temps et même si 54 57 et les
deux d'affilée où il y avait un truc au
mieux
en tout cas
il réalise une bonne partie aujourd'hui
sa cape de corse mais aussi lui qui l'a
fait deux fois 70 et 80 car voilà ça
réfléchit fut juste un petit tour tomber
un réseau bien
qu est relativement logique tu veux
faire des coups comme b4 et prise en
passant reprend 2,1 mais bon du coq et
on est sûr
sur quatre cinq joueurs sans l'histoire
d'être tous les échecs
et en plus actuellement on est dans une
époque quand même très dense
c'est d'autant plus dur en
on sera un peu sur ali reza histoire de
souffler
souffle un peu
mais wayne on n'est pas impressionnant
j'ai un peu je vais ouvrir la porte et
je vais chercher de l'eau
on est plus en fait
d'avoir une bouteille que j'ai à peine
entamée qui est
dans le box a ouais ça fait un peu d'air
en est mieux
c'est vrai que la digue ne vient de
jouer un coup sort à lire et zot sa
prépa parce qu'il ya les avait toujours
très très vite jusque là et donc après
ce coup de tourbe et un jouet par
harding
c'était pas le coût attendu
merci franck l'idée c'est de faire b4
c'est le pion et en cas de prise en
basse on peut reprendre n'ya plus à tour
là-bas qu'ils resteraient emprise
donc c'est une des idées évidemment
probablement la seule idée mais qui est
suffisante pour être
pour être noté et puis c'est pas une
mauvaise chose parce qu'ici toute façon
il n'ya pas de f5 pour l'attaqué susuki
vallier à contrôler donc la tour est pas
trop mal ça va bien de faire b3 b4 son
sabot similaire puisque après on va
reprendre comme ça voilà alors pour
éviter peut-être un programme damas 5
peut être une idée faso puis on peux pas
trop bouger
madame à 5 serait probablement un coût
envisagé côté noir
après d'autres coups comme peut-être
tours 8 j'en sais rien
possible
et donc
ce que ça va réfléchir un petit moment
côté
d'ali reza on a cette habitude dans ce
tournoi va devoir bien réfléchir alors
me demande si fou g4 pour faire flasher
cinq ou six c'est correct c'est un peu
long après pourquoi pas mais j'ai un peu
peur tu perdre beaucoup de temps et que
le jour où tu arrives là au pire il va
te faire e 4 par exemple il va être
bloquée à diagonale donc ça risque
d'être un peu
un peu long pour pas d'énorme résultats
cela dit ça peut être le genre de plan
qui pourrait fonctionner il faut le
garder en tête pour peut-être peut-être
plus tard
mais là je pense comme crime dame à
saint clar à séville s'est logiquement
fait l'annoncé du pion outre bloqué
cette majorité ça donne de l'espace et
notamment cette liasse pour les dames
ça peut donner des coups comme à troyes
par la suite le champion ne peux pas
trop bouger vite fasse cavalier donc
c'est des modérés la structure des
blancs et de deux on évite solution de
poussée puisque ben puisse le cavaly
seraient touchés quoi donc damas 5
pourquoi pas je trouve ça
plutôt logique comme coup
on verra mais ça serait mon prono pour
le cou noir
n'est pas déjà fait nul on me demande
alors peut-être mais je vais les voir
c'est pas noté sur ce que j'ai mais
voilà la position de dépôt alors je sais
plus quel camsell
m aux pilotes la whey rapporte qui est
pensif il n'a pas encore signé nulle
mais donc juste pour vous montrer ce qui
n'est pas là ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'en fait tu rapportes aller manger une
tour là-bas mais les pièces noires
étaient actives et nespouls connait tous
le tempo il a fait se couchera je crois
un peu moins inattendu mais qu'en même
temps et le coeur de la prépa mais le
fond prises mais il faut le prendre
cette dame prend qui va mater et wright
fait des échecs est donc un rapport de
juillet ce qui revient à se prendre
échec et répétitions ou est ce qu'il
tente f3 bon d'après ce qu'on arrivait
avec la turbine est ça va quand même
plus loin la nulle f3 mais c'est
évidemment un coup risqué quand toi tu
connais pas que tu vois l'autre ils
jouent tous tempo et
que tu as clairement de son show de quoi
donc tu dois calculez bien comme il faut
après tu es nul en poche dont clara
porte sur la recherche pendant une heure
dans ses missions il peut à tout moment
il pourra juste faire rage et une façons
les noirs ont rien une affaire qui échec
à revenir puisqu'il en cabine pour moi
donc donc voilà donc il n'a pas encore
fait nul mais
ça va peut-être venir
caruana on en est là ce a pas bougé
ça c'est duda sa couronne ouais donc
tout court ou 5 est donc assez rare pour
le signaler
caruana alors clairement en dehors de ce
qu'il connaît de ces prépas il doit se
débrouiller tout seul dans cette
position
donc le choix malin de la part de
radjabov chemin de la part d' radjabov
et on verra ce qui fait donc on avait
parié sur kalyev 5 évidemment le cas il
ya d'autres cases mais f5 pourquoi
l'idée serait de revenir vers 3 l'autre
en c3 et de jouer pour le contrôle de la
case des cinq qui est évidemment la clé
dans ce genre de position mais j'imagine
que les noirs veulent faire ça ça et
ok après faut voir si à dix coups
concrets comme ça qui marche
la reprise
crise ici on enlève le pion qui les
ferait cavalier
s'est pas trop hein c'est compliqué
comme position
jeunes entreprises ici on a le choix de
prises ici alors peuvent prendre sa part
un peu dans tous les sens donc il doit
calculer tout ça mais évidemment quand
on est au bout de ce sur l'échiquier
c'est pas facile
je ne sais pas ça marche un dessin c'est
juste une idée après si ça marche pas
évidemment les marques juste faire des
six évidemment prendre suis la clé
barbacane cavalli ici et ça ça ressemble
pas mal aux pressions de kalachnikov
juste ce cavalier était ici en deux
coups en 2d cap dans leur d'habitude
fait un deux trois quatre donc c'est
quand même un accomplissement pour les
blancs d'avoir cette position après est
ce que ca c'est pour clamer vrai
avantage je sais pas faire fausse est
une des pleins que j'ai 6 mai on y re
flo7
derock
rock
ici après le cahier à venir la saa
solide rebond après les blancs bien sûr
ils vont faire un truc comme ça je sais
pas lequel un lui
est ce qu'elle est bien là ça ça peut
jouer il est bien placé ce qui veut dire
c'est un peu
l'équivalent de ce à quoi et c'est pour
ça que ce moment en fait les blancs ils
gardent le kenyan ces deux pour empêcher
si jamais les blancs devraient jouer un
coup comme ça sont là ça retombera
jusque dans une posture normale donc
ouais fabi de calculer tout ça mais je
vous ai dit il ya le truc avec des cinq
déjà qu'ils aient pas annette qui
doivent bien dû prendre la tête
5 jouer cavalier cinq vues par famille
et des cinq direct ok c'est ça la prépa
donc
bah écoute et on verra la présentation
il va prendre faby va prendre puis
comprendre qu'à venir ici ça être à la
position c'est assez intéressant
c'est bon t'as trouvé de quoi
tiendra-t-elle
place fassent plus frais
je vais tenir la porte la batellerie
d'accord qu'un peu de courants d'air du
courant d'air je crois qu'il faisait un
peu chaud
voilà je suis de retour ici il s'est
passé des choses et ce n'est pas déjà
fait nul non tu allais voir mais n'ont
de rapport réfléchit après dame échec
chez toujours
est donc là c'est la prépa copulatoire
s'éprend des f-5 je peux quoi peut-être
bien jouer un homme s'est surpassée au
moins très intéressant en pratique et
après je pense
ok c'est bien la part de rajab ne pas
s'enterrer dans dix ans c'est contre
construit caronna c'est un très beau
choix
ces choix qu'on aurait espéré côté
alireza ce genre de position
plus que la catalane contre contre
caruana soirée
n'était plus
intéressant il n'y a pas eu de coups
objets pas raté grand chose enfin entre
autres
intérêts ouais non mais franchement
c'est pas mal
c'est peut-être juste une nouvelle
sicilienne qui débarque sur le marché
alors après je sais pas ce que c'est un
bluff ou fait qu'elle ait réfuté alors
qu'elle est déjà réfuté en fait en
dehors de face et il ya peut-être que
eux deux qui ne savent tout le monde
sait tout mais c'est déjà
ça c'est un truc marrant que m'avait
expliqué bob laddh là c'est souvent 10
en live mais il arrive que tu es quand
tu sors tu nouveautés et tu sais
pertinemment que d'autres dix minutes
après que qu'elle soit jouée en fait des
morts des morts déjà tu peux plus jamais
la jouer donc là c'est peut-être ça
c'est et tu dois tellement travaillé
pour une seule partie
peut-être ou peut-être pas peut-être ça
ouvre des perspectives
à long terme
après furent chassés mais qui rate
maintenant et qu'ils réussissent à être
top 2 dans deux ans que l' inverse bas
après c'est pas si mal d'un autre côté
de vraiment raté ça lui montre aussi
qu'elle sachs à travailler peut-être
quel
entraîneur ou seconde en a changé en
fait parce que je suis ça m'étonnerait
qu'après un tel échec s'il se confirme
que tu gardes les mêmes en fait surtout
un sur tournant mais en vrai c'est
passer la loi de tous les sports
individuels ou collectifs d'ailleurs
mais après un échec tu nature mais on ne
boit jusqu'à l'été que tu te vraiment en
cause des dures travail sur qu'est ce
qui fait un bilan qui s'il était bien
que s'ils avaient pas été bon bah et tu
repars de la banque
oui oui mais c'est juste normal voilà je
pense pas que sainté ils gardent
l'entraîneur non non les gars de l'est
président pons trois parties le
président en fait je crois que ces deux
présidents mais ils partiront jamais en
fait
[Rires]
il va le couler le club en fait ça donne
ses impressions en fait ils détestent
saint-etienne ta
merde non là c'est fou non mais là s'ils
partent pas cette année ça
mais c'est terrible mais pas blitzer
maquis normalement oui mais
on est le 25 juin alors que les
entraînements ne s'est pas quelques
jours ils sont toujours là quoi donc
je suis je suis grosse goutte des années
que je suis mais là je me dis bon on
descend était qu'ils comprennent qu'ils
se cassent quoi mais
non quoi fin
et puis ils sont si mauvais en fait et
ce qui pourrait se remettre en question
j'aurais pu faire un parallèle avec les
échecs genre si tu gardais les
présidents forêt qui change qu'est ce
qui devrait changer
afrique m de plus d'argent ça fait trop
longtemps qu'on vit avec un modèle trop
modeste ils n'ont pas remis en question
ce modèle
est franchement plus personne depuis
plusieurs années donc en fait quand tu
vois des joueurs recrutés en fait c'est
pas vous faire injure aux joueurs
d'ailleurs il y en a un qu'on allait
chercher à dunkerque yvan masson qui la
bat pour tous la repérer ils veulent
peut être le prendre pour quatre
millions et demi ou quoi donc le bon
pourquoi pas mais en fait tu vas tu va
le prendre il à dunkerque rang national
il va devoir direct le niveau ont fait
tanguer tu le post forme et si tu
obliges aller chercher des joueurs comme
ça ou comme krasso à epinal ou tapez eu
les moyens d'acheter des joueurs
confirmés battu chute doucement mais
sûrement et bah c'est ce qui s'est passé
donc le problème de sainté c'est un pas
une d'argent en réalité de ce vol
d'argent ce qui est à toi est ce qu'il
ne serait pas le cas pour fear ucia
peut-être même libyen linverse l'argent
il a lille à nantes lui faut qu'il aille
fils et lui ces puits serait plus le
recrutement qui rappelle quoi basse
synthé du coup oui aprem d'argent mais
de recrutement et peut-être de choix des
hommes parce qu'une fois que galles qui
était parti en tant qu'entraîneur
a pas forcément fait des bons choix un
parent l'époque gasset qui est de la
deux ans j'ai pas de très bons souvenirs
et ça fait plusieurs années que ça dure
et un turc un pas que ça ressemble au
psg quoi plutôt ça serait le signal à la
minute pourraient plus être vers le psg
que vers il ya beaucoup d'argent il y
avait le bon vieux je veux dire le ps
juste ou pas grand chose en fait
badie l'on
trouve pas qu'il fasse n'importe quoi en
fait
elle n'a pas changé son entourage malgré
les difficultés pourquoi les résas
devrait le faire
ouais mais maxime c'est un choix et ses
fins c'était un bon choix ou pas mais
c'est ça déjà été questionné plein de
fois
mais c'est vrai que
en fait avec maxime c'est fin c'est
toujours le sport ça dépend toujours de
des résultats serre que six qualifiés
aux candidats on dira oui il a bien fait
de continuer comme ça s'il se qualifie
jamais un candidat dira oui mais
peut-être que s'il avait changé ses
entraîneurs ça aurait changé des choses
pour rien tu peux pas savoir
mais bon nous on est là pour parler on
discute et aussi je dois dire maxime
wade a peut-être pas il est plus passer
à pas loin de quelque chose là l'iresa
irad vraiment son truc il est jeune il a
le talent pour devenir champion du monde
très clairement tu peux dire
oui ça paraît très logique de changer en
fait ouais je suis à tomber la cabane
structure est née je veux dire même pas
des tennismans même quand tu es très
fort et quand même con ça marche tu
changes des fois oui aujourd'hui il
avait son entraîneur historique il a
enlevé les primes période avec becker et
puis l'a repris nadal il était avec son
oncle toni et puis au bout d'un moment
ça devient très longtemps mais il a
changé d'après carlos moyens federer
modèle centré dans l'historique au début
puis après personne et puis après c'est
un peu mon tour et kate berg avec
ljubicic donc on va être même des
monstres en fait même quand ça marche tu
as encore des axes de progression et la
ville avait changé non il avait il est
vrai fait murray j'arrive à me changer
l'april haendel des primes aux
responsables mansat tu vois ton des
services des trucs donc c'est le cas ça
marche comme s'ils gagnent pas grand
chelem et jusqu'à ce que ça le discours
le déclic en fait après tout les gens
sont compétents gens qui peuvent
entraîner de tels joueurs sont
compétents après faut que le discours
parce que la méthodologie pédagogie être
les bons gros avec la bonne personne à
noter motivation mentale etc
ont boosté pour porter une petite
discussion ces partis qui sont quand
même qui durent quoi il ya le temps on
peut discuter mais c'est sûr qu'à
l'iresa ça peut aussi dépendre de sa fin
de tournoi mais si tu finis mal
normalement tu vires quand même une ou
deux personnes de ton staff juste dans
le mouvement
quartz a été mauvais tout dégage
donc la jeune dame à saint cast et le
coût attendu
qui contre l'avancée du plan b est
active cette dame peut donner des coups
comme à troyes un jour peut-être
dams et donnons attention il ya le
cahier des 4 il faut quand même garder à
l'oeil
même personne dans leur staff ben ils
peuvent en avoir beaucoup mais après ils
ont un ou deux
principales entre guillemets
et derrière c'est plus en vigueur de
l'intendance que c'est pas le mot mais
c'est plus des gens qui règlent les
problèmes des gars qui étaient les
entraîneurs principaux quoi mais c'est
un peu comme au foot c'est pour ça que
je réussis cette métaphore c'est que tu
as un entraîneur principal après pas les
adjoints etc mais si tu changes la tête
tu changeras forcément tous les adjoints
mais en fait c'est lui qui décide ce qui
fait après fin
ça le regarde quoi j'ai envie de dire
pour vous calmer du monde régulièrement
magnus
bon ami sorti au japon ou encore et donc
son mot à dire dans dans sa carrière
donc à prêcher pas dans cinq ans en
disant je veux pas trop m'avancer mais à
l'heure actuelle
étonnant comme choc oui
très clairement
amis qui coûte combien la grosse louche
vous pensez à j'en sais rien mais ça
peut aller
allez ça peut aller dans une fourchette
pour une semaine entre
c'est vraiment une fourchette large me
dire entre 30 et 100 mille euros par par
semaine bon je ferai partie d'un peu
plus bas mais au moins dix minutes je
veux dire c'est sûr alors dix mille si
tu donnes des pourcentages fort way sur
les résultats ça dépend mais non on
diminue la semaine cramique jamais
je pense à un minimum enfin
d'une chaîne et pau on nous dit on
entend ce que parce que c'est une vraie
info chat with roi de bretagne allait
voir prison d'evin pas encore on peut le
mettre en grand écran ça devrait arriver
c'est ça suffit on peut déjà faire un
résumé express de cette partie
mais on bat le record on l'est peut-être
on savait pas si on faisait un résumé
express d ali reza ou des trois partis
ou quatre parties qu'on fait part en
grand format on hésite et mais en fait
avec cette partie elle se fait plaisir
quand même en express d'offres de gérer
même si elle est couplée avec une autre
partie d'un même en grand format déjà
express enfin ça c'est très cool
non mais oui ptête après crâne meek mill
si tu prends beaucoup de semaines moi je
pensais que tu prenais que une semaine
non mais je sais pas trop faim j'ai pas
de
presse en 1900 ça me semble
être un peu beaucoup ouais
faut être un bon pigeon quoi pour payer
ce à quoi
je peux me dire pourquoi ni comment et
je connais les tarifs dizaine de jours
je ne peux te dire ni pourquoi ni
comment chaque scène
j'ai une histoire en tête de scandinaves
dedans entre 20 et 50 mm
pour
gary cahill pas guéri
après 4h15 fêtez pays 15000 euros pour
démarrer nom de championnat se rangerait
mais c'est sa fin oui je suis jeune
homme est mort
bonne chance à tous donc c'est pour ça
une semaine de préparation à 10000 stamm
pour kranjcar est impossible en fait
oui ça après ça dépend c'est un gars
situe là à long terme tu lui fais six
semaines dans l'année oui 7 6 après
après deux faciles ouais
je parlais vraiment une semaine tout
juste passé une semaine en moi je
l'appelle gvt là bien en prendre deux
trois trucs
moi j'étais déjà plus ou moins proches
des candidats alors moi proche que plus
un
nom
très loin les candidats non
faut être dans les tous meilleurs
joueurs mondiaux moi je n'ai jamais été
de
2,2
dans cette caste là on va dire
nageurs français que tu connais il ya
que etienne qui étaient proches maxime
qui a fait une fois et encore ça fait 1
alors s'il a vraiment fait ce n'était
pas les pré qualifiés match mais enfin
c'est l'équivalent des candidats alors
il y avait sept joueurs au lieu de huit
mais drogba qui a fait c'est un format
différent donc élevée elle a fait mais
bon que vous avez vu c'était par bombes
sur rade j étais pas donc c'est pour
vous dire à quel point c'est pas facile
hélas alireza met donc on parle de
joueurs
etienne qui était 8 fois champion de
france mvf qui est amour de mondiale
alliée à jacter numéro deux mondial
et tous les autres joueurs français que
vous avez pu voir sur la chaîne ou
entendre parler depuis vingt ans ils
n'ont même pas approché l'idée quoi donc
c'est compliqué
maxime l'isaf et sans même même maxime
en fait
ce que j en remplaçant
donc pour dire à quel point c'est
compliqué de se qualifier quoi alors
lautier oui mais là je parle des joueurs
récent mais donc lautier et en grèce qui
les avons fait et il a trahi pop des
matchs un match contre et perdre comme
quelqu'un oui une chance comme baky à
l'époque des matches mais bon c'est
différent après c'est difficile de dire
ils les ont jamais fait parce que comme
il n'existait pas
un peu mal au coeur de dire oui ils ont
tu n'étais jamais qualifié oui bon ça
existait pas oui mais détrompe toi
après dans leur format e maxime se
seraient qualifiés à chaque fois lloris
était l'invité l'on en fait
[Musique]
et pourtant très bons joueurs
candidats c'est vraiment
ah oui c'est dur un
intéressant de voir ce que richard va
faire ici ce qui la jouent moins
j'aurais pris nul ans après je reste non
mais là le truc c'est qu'il peut bien
réfléchir une heure ci veut au pire
effet rangé inconscience 10 minutes et
puis tu as mon objet système donc il
peut vraiment calculé comme un full
plein qui peut puis voilà d'après la
houle à pas de chance hier elle a trouvé
intéressant
ok essaie de jouer par harding
qui essaient de hockey
[Musique]
bon il faut sûrement je me fous des deux
il enlevait son cahier des quatre en mer
donc je vois pas trop l'idée du coup
mais le truc c'est que ce qu'on disait
juste avant c'est que les quatre au
moins des fonds dans la case et 5 l'a
peut-être peu développé le footsie a
réussi un coup comme beckham serait
possible ici femmes pour faire une
fourchette prises en ce sens
c'est là en fait c'était cher lui coûta
la vie du
vitrage et un sur b4 on pourrait dire un
fourchette mais faut il penser à cette
prise en passant l abîme
et mes jolis coups jour de mec le plus
forte qu'il ait joué là dans ce combat
je veux qu'on te rapporte par exemple
sinon je veux qu'on traîne
vlc
larry krishna je bande mamediarov
quelques-uns coût
5 tab à 4 ouais mais du coup tour bouge
et
je sais pas quel point tu es heureux de
[Musique]
je pense que tu peux t'en sais-tu temps
passe plus tôt pour l'instant
pique pas besoin d'orange rejeter loin
je sais pas ce que c'est mon pic en fait
mais
le top 6 ans top500 max quoi même sens
je pense pas en fait
c'est quand même pas mal waouh c'est
loin et met ses pas malgré moi
j'en plus fort que j'ai battu je suis
pas gay wyn jones
en partie de l'entente jeudi
quand il était à son tapis ouah mais
c'est toujours toujours le vélorail la
presse que ce qu'il a vu mais il était
déjà 26 50 et là tu étais
même joueur
fantasque ouais mais fort enfin il joue
bien à chaque partie
c'est sa philosophie qu il y
ait accepté comme il est quoi
c'est vrai que j'avais tué mme béland 99
chaude en deux sets mais là pour le coup
c'était pas le même joueur
mais moi non plus
ouais mais en faveur du temps de l eau
depuis 2010 sur un échec il ya eu un
gosse un
jeu c'est pas bête ça sent le diaraf il
n'est pas réputé pour être
stable dans son style de jeu et donc ça
va ça vient et puis l'âge avançant et
cetera c'est pas facile et moins motivés
aussi et c'est dur avec son style de jeu
mammadyarov c'est chaque partie la
guerre quoi ça demande beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de calculs
ça peut-être très bien cette position
pour ali reza worth havre ac / près nul
serait pas un mauvais résultat
aujourd'hui un an vrai bon soit à leur
compte ding je connais personne qui
vient disant oui je vais le défoncer
équilibre je joue si j'ai une chance je
fais déjà du noir comptent ding s'est
bien repris ce que s'ils gagnent on y
croit un peu quand même alors moi non
mais l'on peut pas agir c est que vous
visiez mathématiquement pas fini
un tout petit peu on se fait plaisir
un chouïa
on menace d'y croire c'est ça
si l'on gagne deux d'affilée s'ils
gagnent contre aujourd'hui radjabov
demain
est ce qu on y recourt à un petit peu
tienne question les matches retour c'est
dans le même ordre je croirais on y
croit un peu ou pas
investi dans si l'on gagne trois
d'affilée
3 peut-être un peu
ah voilà ont gagné trois d'affilée donc
si balding aujourd'hui
à drap job of et puis n'a qu'à
la deuxième journée des pannes à 4
c'était rapporte rapporte silva et trois
d'affilée 3 ira peut-être
il faut ça
c'est faisable
pas facile et oui tout est faisable
après je voudrais qu'à un haka c'est sûr
possible hop voilà on y croirait
vraiment la
bonne beaublanc voilà à quoi il a l'air
d'être plus vrai en tout cas son rythme
de coûts est bien meilleure aujourd'hui
ouais bon alors tu as les couilles ce
n'était pas trop dur damas un vrai mais
bon avec leurs précédentes
ouais mais tu vas cette ronde 1 elle
était une mauvaise augure ce damas huit
là qu'il avait mis
avec valdes mais bon c'était là il a
joué une séquence de coûts est évidente
en une heure
c'est vrai que c'était c'était une
mauvaise augure
geoghegan est ce qu'on peut croire à sa
décharge en france ouais bah ça tu
aimais bien sera pas l'an prochain j'ai
connu en ligue 2 déjà remontés ça peut
être une mince affaire
c'est la remontée directe
donc et puis puis voilà on verra mais
oui
ils ont un peu plus square affirment
qu'ils qualifient que ça des champions
de france
si vous dire qu'en
ligue 2 peut-être c'est jouable mais
quand je dis c'est dur aussi
il faut pas y aller en terrain conquis
parce que c'est toujours der steur
pire un pont ligue 2 pendant des années
a été président
lagarde gens pensent qu'on ne peut pas
les candidats ou pour comme ça c'est
pour les candidats non après comme sabah
très bon joueur un maxime
qui paraît un peu le même compteur pour
gwen il joue bien à chaque partie blanc
noir dangereux créatif motivé
très bon joueur
très bon continuer à le dire j'attaque
bien et trouve bien des ressources
bons joueurs ouais mais bon c'est
l'échelon en dessous oui voilà c'est un
vrai c'est pas humain c'est pas pour lui
faire injure mais je pense que là pour
aller aux candidats c'est pas possible
c'est tout
descendu de bah oui c'est envisageable
en fait un
bond la junte semble quand même le
recrutement il n'est pas fait n'importe
comment prend déjà un peu rompu et ligue
2 on a pris un nouvel entraîneur bat
l'ès tu veux bien croire que je réclame
étonné qu'on descende encore mais s'il
ya des guerres intestines au sein du
club que c'est la merde tu sais jamais
si ça se passe très mal que ces
mauvaise ambiance ça rejaillit forcément
document
six matches à huis clos
et trois points de moins
de trois matches à huis clos car s'ils
sont tous et 3
3 avec sursis ou
[Musique]
oms a réfléchi en tout cas côté d'inga
presque racing
côté surpris de l'âge de dubaï j'ai été
perçu de voir quelle hauteur de 20 piges
ab c'est peut-être pour ça que vous
pensez qu'il pourrait être champion du
monde un jour oui non il est pas si
jeune il est prêt il aurait la kalach
non
trois comme c'est un petit gabarit il
fait il fait ici jeunes en fait
mais même dans ces propos
mais bon après il faut parler russe est
pas giga matures
si dunkerque
[Musique]
ça c'est n'a qu'à
bord il coûte ça a l'air d'aller un jour
isolé mais
web en fait il a fait secouer f5 donc
est toujours responsable parce que cet
arrière le pion de 6 a fait un tronc le
5 mai les pièces blanches sont loin 6 au
moins tu blog constatons en gagnant des
cinq qui bloque bien le foot est roi et
donc ouais ça l'art d'aller pour les
noirs après ça peut jouer ça peut se
passer des choses bonjour pression en
fait ils ont stratégiquement
mais tu peux pas
ce que les blancs aimerait faire c'est
de bouffer deux fois en d5
et firefox 4 pour échanger mais comme ce
qui a foulé 5
est lui aussi va changer
a remarqué la tête des cinq n'a pas
foulé 5 je suis pas je serai pas ravi et
que les normes
vous pourriez calais arrivant au 5 juin
quand tu essaies de faire f4 de faire
des trucs après faut voir ce stade sur
le dynamisme pour
moi je ferais bien j'ai trois précités 4
parce que je vais vraiment question bah
oui c'est sûr il s'avère cavalcade
ramdam f3 qui a aidé 3 kg 5 c'est fini
f4 dès lors la cjue vous c'est n'importe
quoi
ouais ouais j'ai envie de padoue dans
mon fou deviendra f54 comme ça car des
trucs mais limite son sera réduit à
penser à des coups comme ça
donc je sais pas mais faut qu'il fasse
gaffe la casse en fait je sais pas à
quel point c'est jouable pour les blancs
ou pas cette séquence et on voit
évidemment s'est échangé trois pièces
légères et que tu as fuck 4 qui passe
peu à peu mes preuves avec maker et que
j'ai déjà vu lors des positions un peu
comme ça c'est terrible il a du mal à
contre même contre maxime boire mais qui
te trouvais le il s'en sortait alors que
ça ses dépositions de deux livres
normalement
c'est qu'on prenne sur france 2 on parle
de quoi
alors foulée 5 passes ratées hyper
logique c'est qu'il ya des cinq ans
verra donc calculer sa tête
3 0 5 me taper jour ne recueille
que
ok bah on va voir mais ce potentiel
danger pour un accord en fait après s'il
ya pas ces échanges qui marche ça va
mais voilà
rien ne servirait pas qu'à juan
mata foot est roi il a pris des cinq
logique
qu'ils aient leur parti
ben je sais pas c'est intéressant comme
position parce que bâle et blanc ont
quand même leur père de fou et le truc
un peu moins bonne mais tu peu rauque
évite de faire tout re 1 et voir quel
point ç'a l'air d'être avantage blanc
ouais mais bon c'est tellement vite on
fasse que peut-être juste ça tient sur
un jeu précis des morts
bref pour résumer extra le parti ali
ozhan on va le faire après une heure de
jeu c'est bien de faire on va le faire
dans trois minutes rapport il réfléchit
toujours
[Musique]
toujours il peut réfléchir longtemps en
fait t'as raison oui alors que nous on
aurait fait nul depuis belle lurette
ont dit pas ça ne se refuse pas
il a pris en d5 ouais
ok on va voir comment la caisse
se dépatouille de cette position mais
c'est pas simple si berne à cas
aujourd'hui pour lui aussi un ce sera
terminé - 1 ouais c'est trop
après s'ils gagnent 3 4 parties
d'affilée savez ça mais en fait tu vois
j'ai du mal à croire que
quiconque n'a pas gagné plus d'une
partie sur ses trompes tu veux en gagner
quatre d'affilée 7 qui restent bah oui
c'est pas impossible enfin je pense
n'importe qui qui gagne 4 5 parties
d'affilée à partir de lait bretons pas
de bonnes chances gagne temps
y'a plus qu'à
6 km quatre d'affilée
a donc du coup il fait le truc nous au
final ils rentrent dans le bon choix
stratégique
des cases noires je veux des comptes
mauvais phu
yen cinquième ici quelqu'un en gagnent 8
da fil à partir de maintenant en fait
même si tu es dernier tu fais mal ouais
ça fait très très mal
pour ça chauffe c'est bien qu'ils soient
pas éliminés des tournois ça permet qu'à
tout moment sur exploit il remonte à
tuer s'ils avaient élimination as tu
serais plus là il serait plus là et
qui t'a sûr qu'ils auraient pas fait 8
sur 8 à un moment donné on n'est pas
bien sûr personne
très bon parce que 14 rondes et là c'est
pour laisser l'exploit possible carence
étaient 28 ans vrai tu vois c'était
comme avant en 28 parties alors vraiment
rien de faire un tour d'échauffement
alireza il serait pas bien parti mais
en tout pour duda ça a l'air d'être
plutôt sympa
wen a fait cette victoire d'affilée
alors oui mais pas aux candidats
bah oui
cela dit c'était extraordinaire à ce
qu'il avait réussi à faire mais oui
c'était pas aux candidats
un truc de dingue quand même oui barbus
et ils étaient tous les meilleurs il
perfore il va revenir on avait magnus
j'ai passé mes modèles qui veut cette
édition mais peut-être des sceaux n'a
qu'à
j'arrive le beau lui à
savoir regardez là les mecs qui a battu
rennes on s'éteint pas y avait mauvais
elle d'ailleurs je pense j'en suis sûr
la stime car au canon
alors voilà 7 sur 7
c'avait été assez incroyable
c'est peut-être c'était plus que fille
je reste que même
les joueurs de ce tournoi c'est hikaru
topalov caruana carmes scène à rognan et
maxime
plus d'un tour en les battant tous way
et dé tous battus puis ça fait un retard
encore gagné 2 après je peux te dire que
en russie après ça si est fou juste pour
dire c'est que l'ami tournoi après enfin
pressé c'est ronde donc laissé 2 sur 7
le deuxième est à trois points derrière
ce thème est venu se
faire après ce tournant en russie
voulait absolument qu'ils soient
contrôlés beaucoup plus contre les vrais
pas mal en russie qui n'ont pas trop cru
mais bon après je crois qu'ils sont très
soupçonnant de tour de kia intention d
ils sont soupçonnés surtout quand c'est
un rapport avec les américains bon mais
bon il voilà moi n'ont pas trop vu ce
qu'il a fait après il n'y a pas
spécialement besoin mais c'est un des
problèmes des échecs d'ailleurs
fait un truc incroyable assouplissement
de tourner
c'est très très pénibles en fait ah oui
pas si longtemps un championnat d'europe
féminin à wissant
roumaine
bombay entre 2002 et 2003 peu importe
donc à des joueuses la plus forte sur le
papier à 2004 quoi mais bon puis belle
comme en super bien galligan tchétchénie
a gagné l'an tête à elles ont fait une
pétition pour dire elle doit peut-être
trichez pas peut-être d'ailleurs mais
alors que y'a rien qui étayaient
s'ajuste ben je vais bien je viens on va
tous les sujets
mais c'est terrible
c'est terrible je veux dire autant moi
je supporte pas la triche mais accusée à
tort c'est encore pire mais c'est
terrible après là ils ont pas accuser
les russes ils ont juste ils ont dit non
attention mais après tu vois sur la
carrière du joueur que c'était normal
comme performance oui c'est
extraordinaire mais il est capable de
fermer ce que je veux dire par là donc
là tu as plus de doute après mais géré
par là que n'importe quel tu as si
demain fille route afin d'offrir aux
gens mais pour n'importe quel joueur
faisait huit sur huit ce qui serait
extraordinaire donc bon là on est bien
sûr on les garde mais c'est sûr que et
enfin
on dirait oui mais c'est vraiment
possible
oui non mais nous on s'en fout des
autres non mais
j'apparais tueur est quand même un
soupçon tu vois un espèce
mais aujourd'hui 2010 by renault caruana
clairmarais
design hand manon attendent avant d'en
avant et
chevron depuis
2006 prend depuis 2001 probablement à
nombre
sur la double décennie et si tu prends
depuis 1990
par apple
je pense assure est-ce que tu l'enlèves
les années 80 quand même
peut-être il était maire jean comment
va-t-on
si tu prends à partir 1992
barroso kasparov s'est jusqu'à 2005 tu
as honte à pas de chance c'est
clairement vicois
à partir de 2050 quand même oui parce
qu'il est parti trop tôt c'est que je
veux dire c'est qu'il a tenu jusqu'à
2005 il n'y avait pas il n'y a pas débat
et après il est parti les parties 1 donc
après quand est inactif pendant cinq ans
bah oui on pense aux autres la cram nick
wey en fait d'un ton tout donnant du
coup mais pas loin mais en dessous mais
en dessous cramique parce que moi non
j'ai vite et jamais gagné moins de
berlitz way
et voilà
mais pas loin gros joueurs évidemment
mais la nand qui encore là et toujours à
la joue toujours bien
même tu as faim chronique sont des
matches de championnat du monde à être
2006 une taupe allofs membres alors
certes il a fait le 2013 c'est parce que
du monde sait les candidats où il a fait
gagner phil prew ex-aequo avec my name
est bon mais à part ça voilà alors que
hollande il a fait deux matches de
championnat du monde sa 3e 2012 contre
l'une des grandes voix là il y avait du
gué de ford il a joué deux fois magnus
il a vu plusieurs candidats afin donc
ouais pour moi c'est devant cramique
quoi la mairie ça se discute même pas
et donc pourquoi caruana plutôt qu'un
autre bas juste c'est le plus régulier
il est resté au dessus de 2008 pendant
des années
son match contre carlson aussi été très
bonne facture et même le candidat
d'avant est finie points ex-aequo enfin
il le truc c'est la dernière ronde ou
cardiaques et des partages à l'épaule
c'est pas comme maintenant match ou quoi
il était obligé de le battre et du coup
il a frappé il a perdu aider ils avaient
des noirs quant au mieux de gagner que
les noirs autant dire que c'est bien
envoyé en l'air j'espérais tellement qui
gagne mais du coup c'est voici juste le
bac est toujours là quoi
et depuis 1960
70 fischer jeu mais fiers devant 4 part
of a je sais pas sûrs mais peu de pain
ça c'est dur à dire mais tu vois si on
fait des décennies à 65 et fisher 70,6
karpov fischer est trop tôt 80 c'est
karpov sûrement quand même
oublier
que ce prof des 80 85 qui passe devant
quoi
voilà j'aurai quand même y karpov
donc ouais
années 1950 à ses preuves en beauté
unique si j'ai pas envie mais
il était trop champion du monde souvent
qu'en
on est en fin de carrière il se la font
quand même ses trente années kid 40
h 20 mètres smith sauf que tu n'aimes
pas parce que je vous aime pas mais je
pense qu'avant tout beau et unique en
fait ouais des carrés
rouges bazini
d'avril h un peu
trop scientifique
et donc 1930
1920 capable en quarts
la sq r1900 1900 le sérère
1890 tennis on a fait nos décennies et
1894 ouais
ouais sûrement sous 40 personnes s'est
un peu avant ouais ils sont 110 -
morphine ans encore avant 110 il veut
peut-être encore un peu chez pas
robin stein rêve et sans titre seul
problème mais oui c'est un gros joueur
et 1910 il était peut-être une pure
classe car j'en sais rien mais bon la
préfète championnats du monde la plus
touchée du monde 7e siècle figure où
l'annoncé 18e
sont 10 michel drucker
je reviens vasile et lui c'est le
transit
donc je vais en profiter pour aller
jeter un coup d'oeil
à rapporte qui a toujours pas joué a dit
rezaï qui a validé cette c'était assez
attendu il ya l'air d'avoir une position
très correct à aujourd'hui alireza il
n'y a pas vraiment de la faim qui a valu
à eux quatre ici pour
pour taper il veut quoi
foulée 4 il l'a pas il se fait prendre
niveau qu avec damas est qu'ils avaient
dépensé cinq dames français cinq tours
c'est un 1er
tour c'est un disons
il veut jouer avec les chevaux
compliqué c'est assez complexe
ces complexes
comme position va on verra bien comment
ça évolue
caruana radjabov c'était un peu là la
nouveauté du jour
position semble quand même sympa pour
caruana
après
il a dû prendre pas mal de temps de
réflexion et c'était plutôt un bon choix
de la part de radjabov mais je pense que
c'est ça sent quand même le truc pour
une partie à fab
le a6 là ça sent le oui
oui oui les
matières à rechercher avec les blancs
pour trouver des trucs
mais non ça semble pas semble pas être
une nouveauté qui marque les esprits
et il a joué il la joue a porté sa porte
il essaye
c3 ce problème de tempo mais c'est vrai
on n'est pas au losc avait déjà fait
vrai bon
paquet
façon il sait que ça va déjà
il à l'évaluation ouais
après ça qui s'appelle devrait quand
même préféré que mon gros face roger un
mois c'était réglé
puis on a rien à [ __ ] et ses
magnifiques
portes quelle beauté il part côté 1
oui
on l'a revu
c'est pourquoi j'ai compris comment
étaient les cales je sais qu'au nord
parcours
une sixième journée de repos pour les
peaux
bas l'année dernière c'était à cette
partie là qu'il avait perdu contre
maxime très bonne partie de maxime dans
la française
ouais j'ai mémorisé lors des caméras
lasser
je suis intenable en fait
là dès qu'on le revoit je peux
poursuivre
la salle de repos va pas me
voir
des télés
et pas de télé
sympa
donc gesca est partenaire officiel de
candidat corps ah bah oui mais pour voir
de telles images quand même ça vaut le
coup
non libre est par terre par terre mais
là tu es zor lobo
el país commune i dat de madrid ya pas
beaucoup de sponsors mon vrai quand tu
réfléchis tu as de journal c'est journal
et je pense que bon faut c'est fou
ressemble plus à argent de l'état non je
pense pas qu'un journal ils n'ont ouais
je sais pas trop en france en tout cas
c'est ce qu'en espagne c'est une bonne
question souvent ces journées on est
d'accord que c'est quelque chose de très
déficitaire c'est une branche tourner à
fond à risque ça marcherait mieux en
espagne
je ne sais pas
ils ont plusieurs journaux sportifs
as et marca tu parles à plein
il n'y a pas le journaux je dise à son
compte à jal au café
je les ai vus comme je peux quoi je
convaincs vous sur 10 mais je pourrais
le sens général et
et je sais pas trop lourd bilan
financière je dois dire mais il ya pas
mal de presse en espagne ça marche
beaucoup en france 1 c'est possible
et là comment il allait
ok et aussi il ya des espoirs des échecs
en fait dans le genre de fans il aime
bien bref une petite colonne avec un
petit exercice soutien et s'est passé
ici saoudite est le parti
un peu plus cette tradition que chez
nous
genre match c'est dans le journal
bonjour un local la tribune le progrès
il ya une petite colonne fin c'est une
bonne colonne donc on va dire chaque
dimanche mais en espagne ces gens se
passe c'est chaque jour c'est plus
fréquent mais
sympa
sky public voir les partitions place non
je crois pas on n'en a pas vu dans la
salle j'ai vu sur aucune photo j'ai vu
de la place pour le public se
retrouvèrent pourtant je n'aime pas son
nom alors je sais comment ils ont enfin
je crois que j'ai compris quand ils ont
fait il ya une salle à côté aux alertes
de suivre les parties sur un écran avec
les commentaires machin c'est sûr mais
tu peux pas le temps au temps de chez
toi après je dois dire que c'est quand
même assez normal pas parce que quand tu
fais un événement sportif de grande
ampleur comme celui-là ça paraît quand
même assez normal de le faire de le
jouer à huis clos prévu comme ça tu es
jeux la saison enfin en fait donc si tu
veux ça ça me choque pas de se dire que
l'on fait un le tournoi le plus
important des échecs sur sur deux années
à huis clos je trouve que c'est bien
pour 9 ans assez et c'est plutôt une
bonne chose
ça comme ça tu vas pas de public autour
ni rien et ça te fait des images quand
même plus clean et en plus ils ont fait
vraiment un truc absolument génial c'est
qu'il joue dans un musée est en fait ils
ont caché le le musée avec avec des
bandeaux de pub à tout ce qui peut être
des tableaux des phases où des trucs un
peu qu on cacher tu peux le voir sur
certaines photos quand ils prennent le
plafond mais tu vois bien le truc noir
qui embellit quand même cette voix
derrière qui embellit quand même très
bien le musée boy
le l'endroit est très très bien choisi
je pense d'ailleurs ça va rester après
des candidats et
avec l'écran genre tenace houmous qui va
bien rester coi j'espère
combien d'heures d'entraînement pour
attendez on a on n'arrive pas bien à la
location pour rester à très haut niveau
ils doivent s'entraîner ça dépend il ya
des joueurs qui sont plus travailleur
que d'autres normalement faut bien
travailler mais
bon cela petit récap
de ski de piau ouais bah écoute on va
continuer un même si c'est quoi les
occuper 17 hockey et on peut rejeter un
homme si tu vas voir le bonjour je suis
mon deuil je vais remettre
dans un halo autour c'est un
pas d'un green n'y a pas de la grille
menace quelque chose
ou six jeunes gens écoutent ding dong
fab on est là pour le petit récap de la
partie
fab on est là pour le récap de
l'ouverture de la partie qui oppose
dingli rénale et réaffirme déjà une
partie des joueurs battus j'ai envie de
dire enfin dans ce tournoi puisque
alireza et dingli renault - 2 et - 1
respectivement
donc ils sont dans l'obligation de
gagner pour encore espérer et dingli
rennes qui a ouvert par ses cartes ouais
donc une anglaise mais il avait déjà
joué ce coup contre nous pourrons d'un
ali reza que ça qui prend le centre j'ai
trois cavaliers f6 fou j'ai deux donc
c'est une des grandes lignes et il
choisit le pouce et cinq taupes rendre
le centre par des cinq très bien détroit
qui est une des possibilités petit rock
et 6 3 ces six pour jouer des cinq du
coup avec les blancs il fait d'abord
cavalière 3 pour attaquer ce pion aux
cinq cas la za défend par des six du
coup empêché des cinq mais bon peut-être
à plus tard petit rock à 5 prendre
l'espace éviter une future expansion des
blancs voilà comment avec les flèches
des quatre réactions central reprend dès
qu'elle prend des 4 et accable bien
jouer l'option n'est pas prenable parce
que c'est de perdre à une pièce fois
cause la surcharge la dame doit défendre
les deux cavaliers du coup il y touche
pas il a fait deux tours bien pour
peut-être cb4 ou b3 qui est plus à tour
en l'air damas cinq évite ce plan avec
des histoires présent passant attention
sur les captures et la prise en passant
donc est il affecté ici de rts cavaliers
du coup les barres sont développées f5
fédé clouage c'est très bien fou des
deux vis-à-vis face à la dame n'y a pas
de grosses découvertes donc l érable
faire club est 17e un petit tour sert
donc on à la sortie de l'ouverture on
peut dire qu ali reza a tranquillement
égalisé avec les noirs et qu'on est dans
une partie équilibrée a chance
réciproque c'est ça s'est équilibré tout
reste à faire dans cette partie
on va le petit résumé express
de partir sur twitter ouais
bah oui un petit régime express
1 qu'est ce qui se passe dans les autres
partis donc duda il a fait ce qu'on
attendait
en fait j'ai trop avant de faire pour
progresser mais si petit müller ou et
peut-être mieux j'en sais qu'avec les
noirs pauvres parents soustraire les
changes s'il enlève leurs fous nous faut
venir le 5 et que les blancs est
beaucoup trop fort donc ok bon j'aime
mieux les bleus voir s'il suffit à faire
quelque chose richard après le dam des
trois il réfléchit
et
et caruana radjabov
ouais
bon non ce genre pression car on est
quand même assez à l'aise au calcul est
faux les profonds faut mais je suis sûr
que ça peut pas aller ça sent plus au
pire des cas avec les blondes est un fou
pro f 6 15 manches qui va s'intégrer au
mieux ça mais en fait et aura un
meilleur foot proposé je sais même pas
si c'était une bonne prépa fait ça a pas
l'air ça l'a fait réfléchir mais
prendre le truc peut-être que là il ya
une femme peut-être qu'il ya un piège
quelque part une idée mais hélas déjà
trop réfléchir sont encore super
préparer pour les arts
écoutons
ouest moins confiants pour radjabov que
je l'était après 20 minutes de jeu
les enjeux de la partie de l'épopée déjà
c'est une prépa c'est le premier truc à
dire donc il connaît les pots et l'enjeu
ben c'est qu'il ya un roi faible et plus
mais les pièces sont pas développés le
roi est faible donc probablement et la
dame peut être enfermé en vingt huit
aussi donc probablement soit y aura un
échec perpétuelle pour les noirs soit
ils vont faire dame des sept cavaliers à
six héritiers gagner la dame en vaux
avec les blancs
pas attention c'est à dire que question
que je pose si tu fait rage et deux
verres je peux même recommencé en fait
ouais c'est qu'il est de nous provoquer
mais si la commune d'assat et
peut-être prendre h3 et fait refouler 6
pour aller mater je vais faire cavalier
assists pour gagner la dame
ça donne pas très envie quinté droit de
laisser la dame à l'autre
je viens du week-end 3-2
[Musique]
après si la paire highway ok mais je
veux dire il se voit pas sur la nulle
même c'est peut-être qu'on s'est pas
vendu assez pape l'autre
17 tempo il connaît bien ouais mais
peut-être plus très éclairé quand même
c'est moins débile quoi parce que là il
se bat on va leur en suis tu vas voir il
est très heureux vim il est là il est là
très très confiant
il est tout ceci il
perdra le sautoir hyper confiant
et la hikaru qui a fait foin f4 on l'a
vu au passage il a
illuminé le bide en face à cilic ou de
byd quand même pour pour bien rappeler
les bases il est hyper confirmé là je
pense que rapporte c'est juste
et bien on le voit un peu dans la télé
de l'autre côté ouais ella a en fait ça
ça qu'elles servent à télé
il est là il va partir hyper vite
regarde team
on a même raté en fait s'il allait
beaucoup trop vite il a décéléré oui par
noah il pas
bah ça fait mal en fait
car oui si un accord d'échangé la prière
quatre ans fait un truc c'est sûr ils
reprochent à la mine tour henri iv
bas il va jouer tactique
insupportable mais bon peut-être que ça
valait 1
voilà oui je sonde après 2h34 bar de la
ville sous donc plutôt un coup de tours
d un pour essayer de faire f3 le dégager
petit à petit construire mais bon c'est
beau quand même signer peau il à +4 il
ya l'irisé peut tellement vite mais
mathématiquement fin à la basse et des
postures continue à gagner tu as beau
faire vite sur 8 sur rossi enfin
il fera que cette mais ça suffira mais
c'est quand même assez incroyable il
regarde moi j'ai envie qu'il gagne
aujourd'hui je suis tourné peau
une très belle prépare non en fait eu
pour nevo caruana que les deux les
défonce le maximum possible et qu après
ça se joue dans leur série contre
j'ai en fait qui
ça va arriver vite seat et la rente de
deux matches aller
on l'aura après-demain cotation là
encore c'est quand même vraiment une
bonne chose que la particule lyon du
tournoi arrive pas à la fin pendant que
ce serait dommage que tout le tout la
qualification soudan un match entre les
deux joueurs les plus forts qu'à roanne
et nepomniachi et je trouve c'est
vraiment cool aussi que ça se joue plus
sur les matchs et voir comment quel est
leur niveau face aux faire valoir qui va
chez le plus de voix c'est un truc que
je pensais qui va être le traiteur quand
je réfléchis c'est
ça la refonte du
[Musique]
du format de matt champion du monde en
fait on va faire plus caruana donc
caronna madaba une maligne ont donné
peau et carrousel mais au lieu de les
faire jouer l'un contre l'autre face à
votre mac de l'effet de ce raid a ramené
des mecs extérieur voir jouer voilà qui
marque aussi des 200 m
au lieu tu vois de bavay logique y
aurait plus de continuité quoi
jeu rendu public way qui arrivait bon tu
vois tiens regarde j'ai battu ça aussi
ça joue chez n'est pas attendre mais en
fait j'ai réellement envie que les deux
gagnent parfois je troll
parfois je troll mais voir un dépôt
gagné savent que je suis un peu niveau
pas très longtemps mais bien avec deux
coups ça va cliquer un
trouve ça chouette téméraire d'avoir
deux rapporte
parce qu'ils la voient faible contre une
dame on va déjà dit maintes et maintes
reprise au portillon
et écoute il a calculé il a beaucoup
calcul est donc on va voir
l'état d'esprit de la porte
est-ce que c'est pas débile
oui mais non enfin il n'a pas fait un
truc où il est perdant maintenant c'est
juste bon
moi j -c laredj autres étaient meilleurs
ouais mais téméraire mais ce que tu dis
moi je trouve un peu bête aux mavericks
mais qu'est-ce qui veut prouver en fait
il veut gagner la partie revenir il à 0
donc si la plus simple mais pau il est
plus qu à +2
et sa partie boisée de se qualifier en
veux tu dire que lui pense qu'il peut
gagner le tournoi ah bah oui je pense à
habas wii motion plus rangée à droite on
a rien à faire rimer mais lui y penser
parce que david oui c'est bien ce que
c'est exactement ce que je disais femmes
tandis qu' il dise kamco profondeur 31
c'est déjà moins 30 quand même je sais
aussi hyper hyper après il pensera pu
gagner le tournoi et il fera il faudrait
peut être mais écoute je peux pas le
voir de l'attitude cesson ça près afin
qu'ils se qualifient pour les candidats
peut-être la dernière c'est probablement
mais - et donc ses chances
bravo enfin géré assez bien
neil est en train de faire la même
partie qui allierait a quand même
réfléchir des plombes pour ça
mais j'ai également vu paul peny oui
maintenant je vis très bien bravo n'est
possible de faire mais
je peux pas en vouloir à porte dans la
proche état d'esprit tout ça prend sa
chance tente sa chance
sur jouer que seydou mais
par contre les balles contre de données
c'est pareil quoi on est rembouser 34 -
nov faut prendre à les deux sont
possibles je me remets
rendu fou personne c'était mon premier
réflexe prêt quand je regarde lui aurait
pu toucher par
applogic du fossile c'est tout sauf le
j'aurais pensé que ça t'aurait plus
kevin martin ouais mais
par la petite nul quand même créé pète
en une demi-heure fait aussi très
plaisir enfin en fait à va dire tu rates
est la seule partie de la journée la
petite nuit a créé peut être petite
plage sera tessin pas là avant de façon
à ce qu'il y ait trois parties à
regarder
il peut jouer ça va y a le droit mais ça
aurait été la seule partie tout doit
être fermé quand même non mais tu me
rassures parce que la petite nul quand
même sur la prépa en vendant son plaisir
à refaire
dans mes chances c'est un mauvais choix
objectivement en vrai je comprends son
choix dans le tournoi mais je pense que
chicken en parlant c'est un mauvais
choix et ça non mais ça me saoule que tu
ali reza qui avait quasiment donne le
point à l'époque en même temps dans une
partie où ces quatre machin et en
connaissant rien là ça peut être jugé
une deuxième qu'on lui donne enfin un
mais bien deux chercheurs qui lui a
donné aussi la première fin
les gens des marques il faut savoir que
y'a des trucs non mais je sais mais
c'est un fait cueillir aux autres
majeurs si ali reza donnerait remarques
il a donné la partie à carmona aussi non
alireza y jouent le jeu mais jouent le
jeu à fond alireza il a filé une année
peau il enfile une ac 1 voilà et ça
c'est beau quand même mais six rapports
si l'on file unis si un autre à karonga
après c'est dommage ouais et va pas
filer en plus n'ont pas filé comme ça
non mais moi je loin de convaincus que
rapporterait perdre
mais il va perdre
je vais après don mais souvent ce sont
les choix dans les parties sont corrélés
avec l'association des tours
c'est terrible
alireza il a donné des points à eux deux
ils faussent pas le tournoi bon jeu
mais normalement il va
moi je sens que tu veux la gagner mais
pas il a l'air tellement en confiance ça
a pas l'air d'être le nez peau en sueur
non mais ce qui est bien pour lui c'est
que ce sont les serres dame 17 tout ça
est que en fait sur un truc 0 0 et que
s'il fait pas c'est qu'il est plutôt
bien déjà tu sais que ils sont couverts
44 - 72 mais bon faut qu'ils jouent bien
quoique c'est sûr parce que ouais je
pense mais ça sent quand même parce que
quand tu as la dame et le roi faible
c'est parce qu'on dise ah ouais c'est
logique que ce soit mis au noir
et enfin ramené du matos vers leurs
adversaires puisque adapte tout seul
peut pas faire grand chose donc va
falloir trouver un chemin pour le
cavalier ou quoi après c'est vrai qu'on
a déjà un oeil sur age 3
je prends mal gagné en fait je pense
à laurent gagner parce qu'on va te faire
f 16 ans wayne d'ofi dam des trois qui
peut traîner dans les parages mais tu
fais ça ouais ben des droits tu peux le
refaire qu'il est mais bon ça veut dire
que tu réactions et des deux serait oui
balade entre en plus l'annulaire la tête
d'homme même d 4d 3 pour empêcher b3 et
préparer f5 quelques avancées 5 et d 3
et machin
six vaches très franchement g2j crois
pas trop
je comprends ton argument dire que c'est
cool de jouer mais non mais si tu es sûr
perdre faut pas faire le con faut pas te
suicider est juste il tape être trop sûr
d'évaluation rapporte der est bon bah
oui mais bon quand c'est pas
battu sans crème but tu peux pas être
mieux avec les blancs non non non mais
après tu peux te dire bon foot
1 sur 1
en fait je dois je veux pas trop qui
lucent pour avons pu enfin
je suis partagé j'ai envie que les
pouilles
chez pas et le lien que c'est un peu
contre lui qui laisse quand même un peu
fabiano faire sa route quoi j'ai envie
qu'ils ont fait ce soit équilibrée que
soit leur mano à mano à mano a mano et
qu'
ils soient pas trop nourris quoi mais je
pensais pas trop la pression me
porte chance à un
scanner pause ça lui convient comme un
gant puissant ses positions il peut
vraiment les jouets calcule bien
normalement
on rapporte par need you points
non mais
c'est clairement la partie du jour en
fait
ouais
non ça intéressant d équilibré donc
s'est pas départi qu'on a tout le temps
mais quand il commence à être un peu de
vous comme ça autour de sa table
tranquille et où c'est un vautour 1 on
le voit dans leur famille ejet ouais pas
que
sur la gamme à droite on va dans le
reflet
mais
bon peut-être il a juste faire un fou 3
tu le saches 3 tu prends à 7
qui se développe à jouer si celui-ci
fait six mois j'étais en train de gâcher
sa
fête à plus de 15 le fou
mais qui l'attaquent belle si la dame
l'ata qui reparaît
mais bon il peut plus sortir en fait
non certains maîtres même si je vais
vous fait c4 au prochain aux photos de
sarah 4 à 5 et à sa case b 6e
je veux dire c'est que je veux bien
enfin même je veux bien croire que leur
soient mieux objectivement mais c'est
pas gagné d'avancé et la prévention mais
nul
ne sait pas quoi si tout recommençait à
débarquer mais bon t'as toujours ton vin
des rois ce faible c'est pour ça que je
vois pas le scénario où les noirs faire
danser
c'est pour ça que j'ai depuis tout à
l'heure je comprends pas le choix parce
que
il a joué au foot franchement mon frère
travaille
en fait je vois pas que mon père
bas
ça aurait vraiment déconné il fallait
mettre le fond j'ai trois et amené tant
sur le thème je sais pas ce qu'il fait
mais on s'est
fait racheter un cache-cache dégage
c'est mon petit passe à côté
peut-être qu'il nourrit
en fait nouveau c'est un leurre de
pac-man voilà
je prends une petite vitrine au passage
faire un poids de 6 places baudis togo
va très bonne question en temps je vais
avoir ça je peux avoir très vite
sur été notre match menant
un set partout
6 4 dans le premier set 6 passes 3 dans
le deux tours bautista
augustin
mais c'est que d'emprunt sera l'ordi est
un peu en suis rendu là en plus il coup
que tu envie de jouer un pur à bouffer
pourquoi pas regarde le langage corporel
de de dépôt
il fait mal hein
ça sent
et on peut avant ce autant c'est vrai
qu'on n'en a pas reparlé mai
mais c'est quand même quelque chose quoi
ouais
non comme jc choix téméraires et tout
mais peut-être un peu comme ali reza
contre contrecarre one eye au monde et
il faut jouer aussi la position est pas
que jouer les plus tôt dans le tournoi
quoi est ce pas aussi
parce qu'il dit j'ai plus rien à perdre
oui mais ce qu'il avait vraiment quelque
chose à gagner
non mais
après deux façons mais non mais ce que
j'ai fais ce que j'aime pas trop genre
je n'ai absolument rien à [ __ ] aussi
mais non mais ce que je trouve dauphin
dommage est ce que je trouve dommage je
vais jouer je vais m'exprimer comme ça
c'est qu'en fait du coup c'est des
joueurs un peu side et suivant la
réussite au moment où tu les joues parce
qu'ils sentent qu'ils sont lors leur
implication ou la révocation le tournoi
ça va changer le résultat du leader du
leader et c'est pour ça que je dis que
ça amène enfin ça m'embêtait un plus
faire ça on va changer je m'en fous
royalement mais j'ai tu te dis oui en
fait ils se font fi des du coup ça va
pas être entre caruana une épaule plus
fort ça va être un peu comment tu vas
bien tomber dans le tournoi contre le
plot qui va donner les points et bon
j'ai un rapport tu vois c'est pas comme
si les fermer le jeu dont deux
caracolent de 7,6 à no 6 c'était chaud
du g4 machin on regardait avec elle bat
là dessus aussi c'est vrai aussi mais
bon là il le fit quand même un peu
passe-t-il ouais donc une heure pour
fait de la merde mais là tu vois il se
prend une prépa de ouf le car ne va pas
planter et
voilà et oui après tout je suis d'accord
que du coup peut-être le format matx
évidemment mieux que le tournoi des
candidates avant une finale des
candidats les mecs se mettre sur la
tronche et le meilleur gagne
ouais il donc j'ai pas envie que ça si
de partout et qu'au final c'est à juste
sur un maintien lui la joue un peu moins
bien contre moi contre toi aller mais
bon ça ce choix de notre candidat même
en 2013 et en tout qui tombe autant tout
le tournoi à la ronde et de bagram nick
même est tombé mais j'étais très
mécontent
j'ai très bien content aussi
un peu ça c'est un peu le côté tu vois
où on fait quand même les choses bien le
tournant est long les cas dans son
ghetto pour avoir du jeu parfait et du
coup on veut bien éliminer la réussite
du truc au maximum et en fait on laisse
un paradoxe qui lui en donne encore plus
que tout le reste et c'est pour ça que
je veux pas que face pour ça que j'étais
pour les nuls 2 rapporte me dire en fait
objectivement si tu sors des trucs de
tournois et de la métare un peu il
aurait fait nul en fait bon choix de
méthodes pas toujours oui mais elle est
favorisée par le fait qu' aucune place
dans tout à fait correct chez le même
tournoi et filles oui bon quatrième il
fait tel truc beaucoup en fait il va pas
oui c'est ça un site en fait tu es là tu
joues tout pour le bien tout le temps
mais
tu t'en fous mais ralenti je prends bien
parce qu'il ya qu une place intéressante
et puis soyons dernier c'est pareil
mais c'est but est de se tourner en fait
c'est là que fait chaque partie sajoo ya
pas deux nuls rapidement raison bien sûr
où ils font rien et là votre fille pas
jusqu'à
chose avec le cab mondiaux l'an dernier
c'était ça mon gars ou à la fin à bavans
gobain maghrébins à tout le monde ça
bien profiter un maximum sur la fin
parce que la partie c'est
alex est une cause c'était 2 2 points
offerts à la fin j'ai joué tu renverses
un peu les appariements cessa pas
forcément être la même chose va presser
le jeu du tournoi mais mais là ça
commence tôt quoi mes ongles avec l'an
dernier en plus il est vraiment finie
4,5 ghana ronde c'était incroyable il
donner tout le temps
triste pour engager
sans batterie est un bon joueur il n'est
pas de la trempe de tous meilleurs mais
ça bonjour
le voir jouer comme ça être
bon du coup les réseaux qu'ils
retournent au travers de réflexion là
j'étais en train d'y penser aussi en le
remettant se laisser un petit peu
terminée se
retourne dans ses travers tu as c'est ça
qui tua quand je parlais de deux
changements dans l'équipe et c'est ce
n'était pas forcément que par rapport
aux résultats sont là qui sont pas
présents mais ça peut arriver en terme
de réussite aussi etc mais c'est cali
raisin on sent qu en fait ça va pas du
tout en fait des multitudes il ya un
truc global qui va pas dans ce tournant
il reconnaît pas du tout et
après on peut jamais savoir on n'est pas
à l'intérieur des trucs monde est là
pour discuter tu vois mai
mais clairement le problème est plus
profond d'eux bon je suis à moins de
apprécié ronde
oui non ces affections bizarre comme ça
c'est vrai qu'elles sont elles se
répètent
ils pensent à ça après oui c'est
possible que ça serve on en parlait
alors de la ronde précédente avec seb
a parlé aussi avec toi on a prévu de
feuilleton soit vrai qu'à part à cet âge
là parfois il ya peut-être d'autres je
découvre peut-être qu'il n'y a pas que
les 64 cases de l'échiquier comme
plaisirs de la vie et de trois tout est
noir et blanc il n'y a pas trouvé leur
nom mais tu vois c'est c'est ça c'est
des choses
qui peuvent russie est arrivée et qui
peuvent déstabiliser forcément à court
terme ou même peut-être à long terme et
on pense regarder ronaldinho au foot par
exemple concernant mais j'en ressens au
bout d'un moment qu' il n'y avait pas
que le ballon qui était en quoi
non mais jure c'est à cet âge là ya
quand même beaucoup de choses qui chante
tu changes quand même beaucoup en tant
qu' en tant qu'humain sortait pas du
tout la même personne à 16 ans ou à 19
ans non
mais c'est vrai après tout le monde se
fout de man from se fout de ma gueule
mais ça va mais il se trouve que c'est
comme ça enfin
c'est pas des commentaires perrinon mais
à chaque fois on fait passer pour un con
comme si l'amour n'existait pas
non mes fans fin mais j'ai en fait je
rigole pas en plus
bas mais moi je pense qu'il trois focus
1 sur le terrain et peut-être il était
trop focus
de préparer neuf mois que à ça pour ça
ça tout le temps ça met une pression
voilà
c'est vrai aussi moi je bouge de là plus
comme ça
enfin je veux dire par là qu'on peut
serrano ça il faut y aussi avoir cet
autre facteur à will power up
peut-être un peu malade qu'est ce que
j'en sais
quelque chose qui peut jouer ça fait
même pas deux ans puisqu'il va changer
de culture partir son pays définissent
temps pour arriver en france c'est aussi
un paramètre qui prend de france mais
c'est ça c'est qu'en fait
c'est un changement et
non sa fin sur grousset perdent trop
monnet léon peut-être après il a
commencé peut-être avoir plus d'argent
de machin j'en sais rien moi la sa
dirigée contre qu'on en sait rien en
fait mais bon ça peut
il a pris des photos un peu tu as vu sur
les îles d'amis sur son twitter il était
fin j'étais content
je pense que tu nous mets à cancun
pendant deux ou trois semaines
je sais pas si on va regarder enfin je
ya peut-être des choses qui se passe
quoi ouais ça me fait penser à
soi dans les caraïbes machin est tout
bon c'est pas en tout cas mailhac il ya
quelque chose qui s'est cassé ça c'est
sûr
mais bon pour eux est une sorte de
confiance de pression je vois mon avis
c'est là et c'est le plus probable mais
il faut pas exclure d'autres d'autres
mais du coup ci c'est bien ça le côté
pression prépa c'est que tu dois changer
quelque chose dans ton staff aussi
verser dans son approche en arrière un
truc qui oui
tu as peut-être été conseillé par des
gens qui n'ont jamais eu même gagner les
candidats non mais
pour revenir plus fort
vous dites
ou sa gaffe de naka
et c'est complètement faux bond ça va
être un ban un qui va partir
faut que je retrouve vous était
si je retrouvais tu as vu
bah oui mais bon j'ai bien dit quand
même dans
avis assez bonne mais
n'y a pas eu de gaffe
on est à deux doigts femme de laisser
passer ça
les rapports du coup il ya eu 3 est fou
j'ai trois forages qui appartient
quel ordi decay ses cinq
amies et moi que j'enrage suisse on va
te fait quoi pour de schiste
g3
qui essaient 5 pourquoi ça se fait
autant
à rebours vous fait lors des huit
admettant
sa tour
est juste eu fait h 5
[Musique]
4 h 5 4 imprime sur f3
en d3 mais en fait le règne c'est que
ton roi il bouge plus et qu'en fait je
fus bouger tes pièces 3,8 des 3 h 4
était bien paralysé la tête c'est ça tu
bouffes lui
c'est ça le problème on est à plus de
coups
turc ouais mais tu as de prendre la f6
g53 g6 1e
tête il va décaler la dame est le pion
h3 et
petit à petit l'oiseau fait son nid
tu réalises que quand tu mets la grosse
turbine cgem moins -3 30
ça m'étonne pas en fait ce que là on a
vu
très paisible c'est pas des coups durs à
encaisser 5 ça c'est logique contraire
de la gueule des pièces le cacit farine
qui avait quatre c'est la pièce forte
des blanches des noms donc hop cavalia
dieu tu le gardes du ku'damm f5 puis
décale tu te places d'ailleurs peut-être
seniors qui est vrai
mais oui il qu'il va revenir vers aussi
ces machins ces attaques tous partout
ouais
ça rapporte a déjà sauvé deux parties
cata
car j'espère qu'à roanne hague en fait
j'espère victoire de dépôt et caruana
oui durant deux ans du coup ça
dépôt a l'air facile c'est vrai pour le
moment alireza renoncer on en repart on
en parlait à 8 minutes est encore en
train de réfléchir c'est
sérieux
c'est même sérieux que les autres jours
ya rien
on n'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi
bonjour
il ya un truc mais on n'arrive pas à le
studio d'amazon
il savait pas non plus
c'est déjà 32 minutes de réflexion s'est
une nouvelle fois après l'ouverture et
en plus c'est sur les coups fouet et
comme tous les jours
non mais la peur de la boule est
peut-être encore avec la partie encore
pour la partie contre caruana je veux
bien le comprendre mais là ils jouent
plus pour rien
c'est ça me fait penser quand des
joueurs de poissons mené 2 sets 0 il
commence un peu à lâcher leurs coûts bon
ils prennent quand même trois sets mais
les petits bras et il recommence à jouer
leur jeu là c'est vrai que si même la
main non il réussit pas à se détendre
le problème est vraiment beaucoup plus
profond systèmes thermiques
une équipe qu'il oblige à réfléchir
longtemps sur chaque nom mais peut-être
que vraiment quoi ya un type à eux les
conseils d'un enfin qu'il ya eu
quelqu'un proche dans son équipe qui
qu'il a mal aiguillé qui a cassé un truc
quoi
ça arrive parce que tu es un coach
réputé ou quoi que tu on sait pas quoi
non mission dépend vraiment et c'est ça
que je veux
tout cas les peaux qui nous fait plaisir
des positions en fait non alors même si
matériellement normalement deux tours
c'est un peu mieux qu'une dame
lorsqu'on regardait c'est que des blancs
du mal à coordonner leurs pièces et ils
ont surtout le roi assez exposé assez
faible avec la dame au tour pour se
balader mettre des échecs le fou g3 est
bien placé pour l'instant maman il y
aura h 5 h 4 pour le dégager de la et
donc les masses cumulée contre le roi
blanc alors que le renard est très
tranquille à se battre h7 y aura rien et
les pièces bien coordonné tu as les deux
tours qui peuvent se défendre l'une
l'autre va te fais pas fait retour des 8
face à dame prenait fin à ses lutins
exemple mais dans des lieux témoins bien
et du coup je t'enlève à thouars fff ont
pu être trois donc il faut g3 prête peut
le chasser donc il ya un petit va ça
vient du roi fait enfin que ça vient
juste du roi faible face à une dame pour
résumer simplement les propos
il sera un
jeu blanc serait mieux en
mieux à chaque
jour un groupe de rock
ouais ça va je regarde dans ce jour un
nom mais ça se joue à une décision de
prendre une grosse fait pas de réfléchir
une heure et de pas dire ok enfin ne pas
accepter que ton adversaire tu as eue
dans l'ouverture et de d'être de jouer
un peu d'être têtu qua
non cavalière de mai kf2 du coup la dame
revient vers ses seins qu'elle touche
ici et tu vas faire rager deux pour
essayer d' un peu colmater tu dis je
défends tout 20 du coup maintenant on
vient de taper la rapidité passif tue
affaires bk pour chasser le cheval 1 qui
avait réussi c'est mon cavalier
magnifique il a des cases gellé plutôt
qu'ils tombent j'en ai 3 1 qui peuvent
je veux te bouffer les trois c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs la meilleure
défense toi tu fais c'est 51 du coup
mais bon on a perdu un oeil à 5 qui va
arriver un jour votre cassette on murray
ouais tu as pu avoir on dit alors la
balade très grande forme et bien entendu
le son je dis merde et des cons mais bon
c'est ces quatre coups quoi
parle de quatre coups et tu attends à ce
qu il est quand même
dommage
il a mal jugé ouais non non mais après
pour moi la situation dans le tournoi le
fait qu est qu une seule place ligue à
lyon vers n'en parle et que tu sois
obligé d'être premier que machin
kinepolis est déjà en violet qui oui si
je fais nul bon toute façon c'est fini
il faut absolument que je le batte et
c'est le joueur le choix assez logique
en réalité aussi c'est un juste un
mauvais choix mais logique facilement
explicable facilement explicable
fothen force terreur un peu comme au
tennis mais après le problème c'est que
l'était pas c'est bien peu par rapport à
ça va tu sais que je peux prendre une
note petrov voilà bon ça c'est 100% ma
vie lâche rien oui mais ces demandes qui
jouait donc
tallage un gros pot avant et tu as dans
un truc où tu te prends un mur quand je
sais pas s'il faut un ordi qui tourna je
sais pas quelle puissance pour voir ça
par rapport à d'autres qui te disent
rien
mais ça aussi c'est peut-être ça mais en
tout cas la table sont que justin arrive
à poil contre
contre le pitre
et oui mais oui ça fait mal mais ça fait
quand même plaisir aussi
la métro on est le sénat le scénario
avec caruana aînés peau qui ont plus de
points 6 avec deux points et demi de
plus ce mode avance sur la mode ça me
déplaît pas comment es tu sais que ça
rend les deux plus forts et puis non pas
sa faim numéro un mondial claire numéro
2 3 clerc voilà ce que je veux dire
ce n'est pas même s'il a perdu des
points elo en fait
là il est saoul classés par rapport à ce
qui doit être largement
entourage c'est être un bon coup il peut
peut-être la défendre on va voir en tout
cas bon il est pas trop bien quoi c'est
pas gagné d'avancé non plus mais bon on
a dit un peu les enjeux les problèmes
auxquels elle est confrontée passent et
plus le choix de d'avoir refusé nul pour
maintenant jouer pour nulle max qui est
un peu bête
cinépop gagne vous pensez qu arsène
jouera lé champion du monde bail sera
tiraillée entre deux choses à mon avis
entre le fait que s'y refuse personne ce
direct n'est pas plus fort que lui donc
mais pourraient devenir champion du
monde ça frère tout le monde bon ce
qu'il a battu facilement et le fait de
se dire bon après même pas être un match
trop faci j'augmente ma légende je me
rapproche dans les histoires de kasparov
petit à petit pour vraiment être
clairement le meilleur joueur de
l'histoire des échecs et c'est peut-être
bête de ne pas aller prendre un match
plus ou moins gratuit quoi donc sera
tiraillée entre les deux mais après
c'est sûr que même si je vous parle
contre les pauvres et que le match soit
pleinement du coup séné peau caruana
comme sait les deux joueurs qui l'a
battu assez facilement parce que l'écart
moyen mais qui l'a battu les nerfs fois
facilement mais qu'il aurait pas pu
jouer contre caruana du coup il ya
personne qui va dire que n'est pas au
cajon à son plus fort que lui non mais
bon le genre du monde était fou chantant
l'hymne on devrait
garder à créateurs aux analystes des
mecs qu'on met dedans des décennies
selon les témoins je prenais binic du
coup je le mets pas alors que c'est ça
se trouve ils étaient plus forts mais
bon là je suis soixante dix ans plus
tard vers le palmarès absolument
alors
disparaître faute grave mais c'est pas
le meilleur
et sireau qui a toujours pas joué
vous envoie de confiance moi non mais
un autre
là c'est petite calotte qu'il faut lui
mettre après les parties
pour le réveiller ouais d'enlacer
on va le mettre en grand plan mais ouais
y'a pas grand chose à dire
il a l'air dépité d'une potion qui va
très bien
je suis sûr que la maintenant dans ce
tournoi à tulle mettrait trois buts à la
pendule il jouerait pas plus mal je
pense que juste plus joué une partie du
jeu d'échecs
mais j'espère qu'il va s'en remettre
t'imagines si peu juste plus jouer
pourquoi tu penses c'est possible non
bien le cioc il est violent
ben matin qu'il y avait un peu réfléchi
mais pourquoi pas il y avait sept ans et
un
dans celui de la digue il fait aucun
coup fort c'est pas des mauvais coups
oui me fais rien je
suis ici sud pas ou d'un mât s'est tout
d'un pays si j'en avais la séquence des
blancs c'est dormir je me décale d'un
coup sûr sur la gauche qui avait des
gars qui décentralise je la remets dans
ces deux jeux mais un fou d'une caste
des deux rames et matois khaddari coût
des blancs qu'ils ont c'est pas des
mauvais qu'on soit en gms
raison que ça va tomber à l'aise comme
ça
c'est stressant
croisions pas sur autre chose
oups un grand
ouais mais
ça va pas trop gros que je pensais
safina
on dit que ça va pas trop parce qu'on
imagine
1.5
bas puis main dans ce sens que le roi
est un peu faible après bon il a trouvé
un truc pour la pression sur la colonne
des dons qu'ils veulent dans le foot est
roi fort de scandinaves
je reconnais
et ça a joué je crois côté un dépotoir
défendre ça fait 3
1 trois bombes il va faire son petit 4 c
5 j'imagine
à cinq noms
il peut
quel parti quand même
bon
valait pas mieux australe a dû s'y
mettaient pas n'est pas dans les favoris
non mais jamais
non plus mais c'est
en fait tu peux pas ne pas compter sur
lui toute façon
mais il est trop
fluctuant oui mais si tu réfléchis bon
mise à part car c'est le match contre
400 c'est quand même un truc particulier
mais championnat de russie les derniers
candidats j'aime bien jouer là ils
jouent très bien pendant les grands
rendez vous j'ai l'impression qu'ils
commencent à vide à peut-être trouvé la
recette en fait
il va peut-être changer et on s'est pas
mis à jour qua non après quand il vise à
les brosser pas lewis étant sans enjeu
en fait les grands chefs invités pauwels
il sait qu'il était juste pas à fond
quand justement
s'en fout
mais bon je comprends très bien c'est
donc un regard caruana il a fait pareil
certes mais j'ai relaté un gros candidat
hop
c'est peut-être ça la vraie meta en fait
c'est de jouer très mal
tout le temps sauf pour les vrai
tournant pour se qualifier pour le plan
d'aidé mais regarde on y réfléchit un
dépôt et caruana là il en dehors des
candidats il faut oui quoi
on n'est pas en fait c'est simple il a
planté le gagnant le 6 ça ils empêchent
les deux tours blanches de rentrée il ya
différents 17,6 à l'amusement
ya tout le reste et il commence à
envoyer un peu les pions vers le roi de
la paix il joue vite
mais il met pression autant quand même
même si on au 29e coup et que etc
rapport devrait facilement arriver au
40e
à voir car le sait nos candidats ouais
ça serait intéressant c'est ma vie mais
c'est avec le format de faire un
candidat pour le titre mondial ces
patrons
avaient fouillé une phase finale à la
coupe à la fin
on vient d'ailleurs
sur ce candidat là ce qui semble se
dessiner c'est vraiment que tu auras
envie de faire je les deux premiers dans
un match
[Musique]
hi fi route châssis vous faites non mais
c'est faux il réfléchit encore rapporte
jours non
non nouvelle jouer contre carl scène
pour bien jouer pour le prochain
candidat un vrai champion est magnifique
en fait du repère il se re qualifie
magnus leur défoncé un fou c'est la
boucle quoi
rire jaune
ce qu'elle veut elle aurait pu prétendre
au titre s'ils s'étaient qualifiés bain
dur à dire mais bon
encore une fois très qualifiés thatcher
tes chances d'un match donc il veut
c'est des choses mais en soi amérique
vous dira sûrement pour les candidats
sa formation de carlo scène bas les
candidats et ceux qui ont la chance va
tout le monde a ses chances avant de
tourner de façon tu peux pas trop dire
si ces huit bons joueurs
et d'ailleurs quand il l'a joué il
s'était plutôt bien comporté
sur cuir rouge en fait il est peut-être
dans la salle des temps de 2 des bzm à
l'envers c'est un truc qui accélère très
accéléré couaillier fut arrête enfin il
a toujours pas j'ai
des plans
un match des oranje en cendres a déjà
connu ça que tp ton coin tu vois plus
rien en fait g data le cerveau qui
tourne en fait la méthode c'est le tempo
mais bon tant pis mais moi ta main elle
est encore là on servait plus à
ces terribles
cerveau est en panne
fringale quoi
ouais c'est vraiment de la préparation
et là c'est quand tu as confiance plombé
meilleur cheval dès qu'ils l'ont vu ils
l'ont trop long vu trop beau il s'est vu
trop beau ils ont donc on flattait tout
ça mais oui tu es vraiment très fort
mais même vlad est plus faible que toi
oui bon on rediscute vous adore je
construis krikor le prochain match
enfants
wen ont bien mais là oui c'est ce que je
suis d'accord avec ce que tu dis oui à
100 % ça ressemble à ça c'est quand il
ya des jours où tu regardes l'échiquier
tu vois rien il se passe rien en fait
l'histoire
oui là mais seul méta naturel d'attendre
une chute 1 mais la méthode cyclique
dans ces cas là il faut cliquer
peut pas être pire toi son nom
mais au moins tu piques
vers la méthode c'est toujours cliquer
jardé politique
c'est un tout petit peu sur ali reza
après vous comprenez je pense qu'on
avait dit qu'on suivra en mail mais à
tous ceux qui s'en posent xiiie où est
la position et pas spécialement
intéressante et ça plombe quoi
non il est pas un peu mieux bref je
pense est équilibré composition mais il
n'est pas du tout mal avec les marlins
ont fait plusieurs victimes elle va très
bien
tout seul alors damas est pourquoi pas
en soi c'est un coup très bien tu t il
t'en fous tu regardais arrive deux tu te
lèves du vis-à-vis face aux fous des
deux c'est bien ça bon coup mais qui en
bullet ira jouer
logique
on lui montre que les autres quand ils
ont remarqué ils ont envie de cliquer
vite parce qu'ils savent qui replonge
derrière
[Musique]
c'est tellement compliqué le haut niveau
ce qui est très marrant plus avec she
wrote chasser que de base c'est un
joueur internet bullet belette quoi
bon après c'est une bonne chose c'est de
prendre son temps mais un peu trop son
temps
en temps un peu sur les peaux ça m'a
l'air d'être une partie importante juste
en fait
je ressens que c'est la partie
importante dans l'avenir du tournoi en
fait
sur ce il ya des clés noires encore
un petit poucet fin ça peut aussi être
la partie qui gagne pas et qui le dit
qui le met un peu antique je sais pas
j'ai l'impression que c'est une partie
qui vaut cher quoi
burger pour l'instant je crois qu'ils
lâchent 4 puisque élèves de
chasse la dame et il va récupérer h 4
sera le coût viendrait faire
quand même hein ça se regarde
ouais mais ça sent pas le meilleur a
envie de donner h pour donner à chambley
en fait je venais juste de 9,5
maintenant et
mais du coup c'est pas mal répartie 2017
up
reprendre tout de suite au moins quoi la
première poule après coup de la turbine
c'est le couple avait tout à l'heure en
fait non mais c'est pas m -cd
prophylactique il veut faire b4 il veut
faire son muret tully banon bons fous du
courant et chutes il va rester alerte il
pourra faire des choses plus tard et
puis voilà
ok car bernard est ce que je sais
ils dingila jubé 4 à bab jeu c'est sûr
qu'eric ligue b 4 vite
paris la clique des trois guerres mais
c'est exactement la même chose
c'est reparti pour dix minutes alors que
c'est le coût principal des trois
pays
je sais pas trop quoi dire en fait c'est
vraiment preuve de confiance de
s'attendent pas et que je pense aussi
autre chose c'est quand t'es pas en
confiance thème jamais tes positions
oui elle va pas aimer je ne sais pas
quoi ça fait objectivement ça va en
effet deux matches il ya un truc de le
déranger j'avais pas savoir quoi et lui
non plus fins
s'ajoutent à ça va beaucoup moins
dans le rythme il ya quelque chose qui
est mieux que les autres jours
après c'est vrai ça car on n'a
pas ce qui est un bon coup
et la joue et dames f5 wa boufarik
mais c'est vrai que j'aimerais bien me
proposait à cinq ans soit
tu évites b4 qui est priori le
reste est pas à mon cou et un coup
j'avais bien plus tôt et qu'il a été bon
d'après alors dit dans ce tempo précis
on passe d'être il envie de mosquées g5
et menace est comme
[Musique]
ça c'est un truc ça qu on nous a
recommandé dans les vidéos de moins
parler avec les coordonnées et de plus
parler à mettre le cap à l'est vers la
gauche à côté de la dame est ou pas ce
que vous en pensez
en fait ça dépend quel public en fait en
gros il ya un langage échec non faut la
prendre c'est comme ça en fait on parle
comme ça après c'est sûr se trouvait
devant débutants c'est compliqué
d'entendre les coordonnées vous ça vous
dirait et bonfossé
après ce qu'on essaye de faire et qu'on
fait toujours ce qu'on fait des flèches
on glissait un maximum m 110 kg 5 quand
on voit ça c'est ont fait pas un piège
aux flèches en h2 quoi fin
mais oui si on fait des formats spécial
débutants
on pourrait noter les coordonnées
je sais pas vous connais pas assez pour
dire
et puis tu vois pas il faut pas brûler
pour un tournoi raté
mais faut tirer les conclusions donc des
choses qui allaient bien d'autres la
prépa c'était bien
ce parti dit qu'on a normalement ce
procès bon moi je lui conseille quand
même de regarder des parties assez mieux
ça que
regarder des gens qui jouent mal
passé huit heures par jour dessus mais
on a un peu ce qui se passe et écouter
les conseils vont appeler ouverture m'a
pris je veux dire dans les grands
maîtres l'on connaît peu qu'elle regarde
les candidats battus regarde pas toute
la journée alain resnais et souvent ce
qu'on fait oui c'est que tu te balades
tu regardes à inventer à son nez ou du
coq l'ouverture à ok nanana ça c'est pas
mal ça intéressant bon et puis tu revois
un peu plus tard et puis le soir et puis
peut-être une partie chaussures à losail
t-notes mais déjà pas passé les six
heures d'affilée dans le monde fin et le
dira qu'ils font mais j'ai en moi je
fais pas
un peu qu'ils le font avant tout car le
sang et ça en corse et les grands
maîtres actifs sains les grands matinée
actuellement
ça je veux dire que trois premières
rondes quand j'étais privé que top 12
n'a pas regardé une seconde 1
les débutants regarde pas les pros non
plus quoi faire personne ne regarde
il a fait un faux b4
est ce que l'idée ch4 ici et c'est à
dire que surprend cavaliers f4
c'est pour des deux ans aime et qui
s'est réveillée j'ai ici c'est prendre
après ils bouffent la même si tu vas
dire la vache sera
donc jean raimbault femmes
ok donc h4 tu dégages et ça c'est sûr
qu'il a vu le type ont abattu sur ce jeu
5 pour ça vous enlevez le fou
je passe sur amby 800 m2
est
- ce fut l'âge qui avance sac c'est
plutôt plaisant pour les blancs par les
noirs pour les noirs et
ces données que ceux des 4
g passe à 100 ça sent vraiment il a joué
quatre tempo s était sûr qu'il y avait
ceux qui possèdent allemande
a donc surtout parce qu'un problème
c'est qu'après les f4 silva touré sur
l'a6 la tour par jaka et j'ai ici si on
mange et si la tour est il ya des matchs
trois et on fait une double attaque un
projet lui même plus riches travailleurs
dans le cas où il faut pas prendre
donc voici fois ce doublé vite après
rien
parce que je vous dise ici à juste vous
prend fous ils peuvent apprendre du
cavalier aussi est clos il faut pas
prendre de la tour eiffe trois
des six exclus est ressorti en baisse et
bouffer donc
pour ça qu'on dit [ __ ] f2
[Musique]
hyper fait germer omc son adversaire qui
n'a pas voulu perpète caruana ça l'air
de bien aller pour lui aussi la minime a
fait retour des cinq échanger ses pions
de plus alors c'est pas gagné encore
mais bear
peut-être pas gagnant non non non pas
gagner et
gagner pas de discussion possible
c'est à quel point finir ou tour 8 qui
valait 1 4 sa clique
ding qui veut sont pas se [ __ ] cases
noires être le cas il va gagner la paire
de fou après bon ce qui avait eu 4 par
exemple
comme ça mais on leur fait un cahier ses
cinq fautes 3 je pense
du ramadam
hockey et ça je vous qui êtes fou qu'a
très bien non ça il faut vite le calme
finalement il fait ce qu'il faut faire
mais je regarde pas mal on se débarrasse
de la paire de fois de faire son fait
mais ça va un peu parce que les blancs
pâte faiblesse et north ad6 à peu
arriérée après toi là toujours écrire ce
que veut faire des cinq un moment il a
tu as complètement
[Musique]
sa passe pas grand chose en fait dans la
partie en soi non pour le moment il se
passe c'est plus d'aventuré la pendule
que
douze appareils en fragrant vient de
voir conseil évolué en fait on a dit
donc il a le bon candidat cavaliers
contre le mot il faut
le truc c'est que ce qu il aimerait le
transfert à 1,5 un parfait c'est une
bête quasi les mieux dans la soirée chic
et coupe la liaison des tours soit
colonna est bon encore faut-il y arriver
parce que pour l'instant qui a été
trompée en d4 lacasse active tant qu'ils
appuient autour mais est-ce que donc il
va arriver un petit à petit monter sa
position et en profiter tout son travail
à faire maintenant
mais plus agréable pour les banques
matin ses avantages mais quand même
c'est sûr même plus qu'agréable
forcément mieux
mais bon très actif les normands
détourné
et donc la partie pour le moment
du jour
liane qui met une grosse pression sur
richard qui pourraient s'offrir une
nouvelle victoire express 1
un grand gouffre à baie
c'est ce côté car menacée puisque pouces
atteint ses pions plus d'aplomb avantage
est
là dans les leaders les leaders qui
montre quand même qu'ils sont plus forts
quoi
s'ils gagnent tous les deux ils vont
faire un tel écart sur
son lait soit ils ont un point et demi
d'avancé sur les premiers poursuivants
c'est énorme après ça tremble
séquencer lundi n'ont
pas normalement sauf s'ils ont changé
l'ordre des partis au retour mais
c'était la route de la phase aller donc
j'imagine sont des phases retour à
l'abri de rien dans l'organisation
mais pas une grosse hype comme fil rouge
parce qu'il à 150 points d'eau de moi et
c'est pas comparable pour l'instant
après on verra s'il progresse guînes 100
points elo
ordinary poteau un bon il ya déjà eu une
petite hype autour de progrès d'andorre
quand il a commencé à débarquer à battre
les grands maîtres est devant être très
jeunes etc c'est pas passé inaperçu
d'ailleurs on avait fait des vidéos nous
ah bah oui en 2016 à l avant du monde à
caen sur lui donc
voila mais après il ya pas mal de bons
jeunes
jarrad 12,7 au raphia pas de hype mumbai
et champion du monde rapide on s'en fout
en fait
ça mais c'est une mine vraiment on s'en
fout bon en partant c'est pas mal quoi
ta sinda raf
taeguk est un ado tu as plein de jeunes
indiens
j'ai pu j'ai pas tous les non mais
et donc bas dans toute cette vague de
joueurs certains vont émerger de
nouveaux restos y sont on verra bien
mais c'est toujours dire dur de penser
sur les jeunes
par définition ils sont jeunes quoi on
se dit tout le temps je sais pas comment
ça va tourner sont d'autres intérêts si
on continue à travailler à fond si
peut-être juste avant de mettre cap et
qui ont été un peu dopé à la prépa
machin et que c'était sur entraînés ils
ont eu plein de trucs et qui comme ils
sont jeunes sont encore motivés d'après
le vite et qu'à un moment bas il manque
un truc dans le fond de jeu et ça
manquera toute leur vie donc voilà dur à
dire après ils ont a priori le potentiel
pour
on verra
je vais essayer les deux mois qu'avec
cinq murs tasse pour apprendre les
échecs voilà
je sais pas pour qui ça va être le
plusieurs conversations pour sa revanche
je pense pour sar de hpn
ce qui est sûr pépite française à part
firoud ben peut-être maori dit peut-être
materia mais c'est encore très tôt ils
sont très jeunes et un petit jeu vous
bien ce petit collège il ya
huit ans j'ai
très bien pour son âge
entre parle quand je dis les gens sait
pas on sait pas quoi mais là et vous
bien
meiway
reçoit plein d'autres bons joueurs
jeunes français mais
fais pas ce que tu appelles pépite en
fait pour être grand maître et n'a
peut-être pas mal mais à pour essayer
d'être champion du monde ou quoi c'est
une autre histoire
maryse il impressionnant quand même bas
il est très fort mais bon quand tu
compare avec le store programme en bas
ou quoi je sais pas un temps de passage
ou et m'a dit à quel âge un marrant je
sais pas après il est vraiment sans
alors 15 environ
il est très très fort quand tu compare
au commun des mortels c'est
impressionnant même où comme un des bons
jeunes mais après c'est vrai qu'on le
compare forcément avec ali reza avec
km/heure avec praia landes avec neeman
il a 15 ans
24 90 15 ans enfin c'est fort mais c'est
pas non plus 20
ça rien en fait non ses formes a fait
faux voix progression quand je suis
passé bref faut pas s'inquiéter ça bouge
pas trop aussi perdu travailler qu'à un
moment ça mais je vous dis dur non c'est
trop dur trop jeune
plus tard antitank passage des jeunes je
sais pas
pat locaux vides
finalement on n'a pas été moi j'ai raté
plus loin de jouer mais en fait tu
pouvais jouer ce niveau là il y en a
plein qui sont les jolies tournée en
espagne tu peux aller jouer dans
d'autres pays en a plein qui vont serbie
jouer enfin tu peux jouer à droite à
gauche donc il ya plein de jeunes qui
sont allés faire ça en fait un
plutôt les mecs de ma génération qui ont
perdu pas mal de voir les joueurs du top
12 on en parlait
et des gens que je connais mes parents
pour l'équipe de bischwiller my [ __ ]
qui est de 1620 alors qu'il ya de 1730
rothstein 1580 kg et est de 1700
ragga requis à 2632 2700 baky la plume
26 40 alors qu'on la connaît plus 2007
fraisse pareil maso 25 25 alors qu'ils
étaient 26 30 en fait tous les joueurs
dont on a tous laissés en fait donc
c'est plus les joueurs là qui ont
souffert que les jeunes jolies et jaune
pour le coup bah oui avec s'affairent à
travailler
donc je pense vont plutôt progressé en
fait donc je sais pas pas d'accord sur
l'argument
ce qui est logique mais comme je suis un
gros vide c'est ouais on est trop fine
en trois mois mais après si tous les
jouets à l'été 2000 20 tu pouvais en
fait
en plus ces jeunes faut dire qu'il
n'avait pas l'école bah oui je n'en
voudrais que ça il faut être avec comme
des fous et hendaye qui ont fait que sa
raison
mais quand on est adulte c'est un peu
différent bah oui
derrière toi tu dois quand même gagner
ta vie tu te l'a gagné en jouant des
tournois de plus je voulais tourner donc
du coup tu donnes des cours écoute je
travaille pas pour toi ben c'est notre
histoire
et on va être tas d'autres choses à
penser en confinement compte adultes
si ça quand tu es enfant tu as le temps
et c'est tant mieux heureusement
ou b vite reporte
mais
mais oui donc difficile
de savoir ce que ça donne 15 en 2005
santé sur le banc c'est sur de bonnes
bases ouais mais bon mais si à 17 ans
t25 80 c'est déjà terminé pas terminé
mais oui c'est de moins bonnes bases
voilà 17 18 ans fait plutôt vers 26 50
kw à venir 18 ans faut être 26 50 euros
- moi je sais pas ce genre de beenie man
il allait vite oui animal il a commencé
pour elle plus tard
bien que j'en fait 18 avril à l'aise il
a faim il a commencé les échecs très
tard
c'est complètement différent du man un
peu c'est un peu bizarre
mais il est déjà à 27 à 19 ans quoi
en bref voilà
on sait pas on verra bien
bah c'est pas si t'es pas ils sont 50
disons pas cet avis c'est juste que tu
veux être champion du monde et l'on
parle de ça en fait
il faut quand même être au moins 26 à
mais bon après la différence entre 2005
et 2006 à cet âge elle peut se combler
très vite en ça peut être un ou deux des
cris qui et bim passe de 25 à 26 ans 6
mois
généralement il en est où km/heure boy
joue pas mal mais bon il est pas encore
au top pas
sûr que tu as passé de 2006 26 70
imprudent exactement il est vraiment un
cavalier g5 hockey
26,75 bah c'est pas vrai il a 17 ans
ce qu'on disait
il 26,86 même sur le classement live
pour sa rigueur oui tu vas marquant si
dans deux ans il est juste 25 80
gaffe
attention manière pour
après leur dis aime pas trop mais gaf
chambre pas de manière à contrôler gaffe
mais du coup j'ai pas ce qu'on appelle
les gars faut pas gaffe et les uns que
j'avais dit que c'était pourquoi le coup
de concert
pourquoi n'aime pas il faut faire
peut-être temps alors dit assez loin
jean st
ça pour protéger le pion est sûre ça et
qui est des six
vous prendre au point fr déjà ces
trouvailles mais bon c'est pas facile en
participant ses attentes bref un fou
prend encore preuve 3
24/10
3,3
à ok bon
déjà c'est dur et combien on n'est pas
obligés chaque épreuve 3 du coup les
points 4 évidemment papillon prend il y
aurait d'arrêt fin match mais tout
reprend je crois
encore enfin ce n'est pas sorti des
problèmes avec son jeu 3 ok c'est pas
grave il a fait que les fait tourner on
est sûr qu'ils prennent ce qu il veut
juste aurait foncé
sur pied pour le cas tu veux quoi une
dame
bah c'est chiant c'est pas trop dégagé
adam battant 3-2 j'ai juste fait mon
premier chèque way et aa3 qui saute
à mais en fait maintenant tu
[Musique]
prendrais faire ces cinq
trop bien son homme rêve de
ça va être dur un
ça va très dur
bien les pots
et caruana
il a fait le tour des 5 1 ouais et il
l'a soutenu par un fond ces quatre
écoutes on va voir à quel point ils
n'arrivent à convertir au pain c'est fou
toujours opposée non comme davantage a
dit ça favorise la tacc fusion veut
recomposer le fois peut-être venir en
dessin est très bien placé après le pion
de plus il a un peu anecdotique
l'allemagne d'être là sains et puis
pourquoi pas un jour ce sera peut-être
moins anecdotique si pur f7 est plus là
tu plantera un truc dans le 6ème
l'actuel c'est pas ça
mais bon capital quoi mais
ça peut le devenir mais ça peut
allier reza quand même je rencontre
des cinq bon bah ouais on dévalise les
bases de son pion potentiellement faible
espoir en chose dans cette partie en
fait
rien il a villa il a égalisé très
facilement
qu'il pensait cinq dames français
5e au 3e
tour prend 3 un coup
franc est en confiance pour le jouer
vraiment il faut des quatre
et six au fc chooz mais faut déclasser
un problème donc ok vas pas te reprends
le 3 mai pas besoin de ça on veut juste
rang de ces 4 et reprendre et puis
pas la partie la plus au nord près bon
après c'est une baignoire soit 12 us qui
l'a pressé
je sais pas même ses cinq peut-être
mais prendre l'espace en fait
avoir c'est intéressant à voir comment
ça se passe et sexy fait à quatre baies
5 y dégage ce fut aussi un petit tas de
plus de problèmes sur des 5èmes a4 a5 et
tu dégages la dame d'ici et après tu en
as caïd étroite aura plus le problème en
d4 donc ok tu as des idées way
un accueil va devoir être très mais bon
c'est son domaine en ont mais être très
concret très précis ouais alors un ordi
va défendre ça parce que justement ils
sont très précis c'est hyper dur sa
passion fm dégueulasse stratégiquement
ça signerait la fin des espoirs de naka
une défaite aujourd'hui surtout si s'est
conjuguée à une victoire de dépôt
mais pau qui met une pression de dingue
un jeu vite
eh bien
oui quand il joue comme ça il est
vraiment clair numéro 2 3
facturé s'est rendu compte qu'il aurait
pas beaucoup mieux qu'une nul et donc il
était définitivement out un peut-être
ouais voilà façon s'ils ne gagnent même
s'ils gagnent en vrai
ça va commencer à être dur on est
d'accord que rapporte ses prix une prépa
évidemment un grosse prépa de yann
qui a envoyé vite et fort
il va être un super il doit être
difficile à jouer ryan maxime après par
exemple il a plutôt de bons résultats
contre yann je pense dernièrement en
tout cas il y avait failli le battre
au grand-duché ce tour il avait battu
aux candidats
il avait mis la pression dans la partie
décisive avec les noirs d'ailleurs
c'est une préparer pour le championnat
du monde probablement en mai
maxime et des ponts ont un peu le même
s'ils ont un style proche ouais mais
ils ont quelques quelques différences
quand même
l'année peau qui calcule
c'est fou que les peaux et réussi à se
relever comme ça après la claque qu'il a
pris contre carl scène et rennes en
solide un honnête mans on avait peur
pour lui qui sombre mais en fait ça n'a
pas trop affecté
et ouais maxime avait battu jan simko
fiscale dans une partie qui lui avait
permis de remporter le tournoi avec un
cavalier qui avait dominé un fou de
cases noires qui était resté derrière
des pions dans une tâche dorff
qu'un dépôt
qui est présent
qui essayent d'ajouter un chef-d'oeuvre
à sa panoplie dans ce musée madrilène
bon un peu d'eau
c'est mikko il s'est déjà mis son badge
devant et ouais non c'est pas de la
bouffe ils ont un gros match en fait les
joueurs j'ai postulé à vue sur les
photos ils ont un très gros badge la
taille du badge est assez assez
impressionnante
non mais vraiment genre c'est un [ __ ]
de deux carrés de 20 cm ou 30 cm un truc
énorme
ça met en lumière la perte de magnus
quand même le niveau de yann ouais mais
après magnus aussi c'est un joueur
dépose nepos un joueur qui convient
comme un gant à magnus aussi un il faut
dire que dans l'eure
dans le duel d'homme à homme
n'est pas
beaucoup plus de mal à faire
à mettre en difficulté car le scène que
l' inverse
imposer ses positions ouais
j'ai appris en regardant bien jouer donc
il va prendre du plomb apporte ça c'est
sûr
s'engouffrer à priori bref 2
c'est chose faite fab
c'est très pénible pour les blancs il
doit regretter un
de la voir jouer c'est là richard
joueur hongrois apparemment pas encore
roumain
il va le devenir quand il jouera plus
les candidats c'est pas le bon timing on
n'a pas pris le bon droit
c'est ça ouais bah y avait il ya eu du
jus dit quoi à judith y avait des co et
c'est un beau pays des chèques mais je
veux dire là il n'y a pas d'autre dieu
que rapporte
et pas du tout d'ailleurs enfin il n'y a
pas photo
mais donc lui qui va devenir romain les
jazz venu je sais pas enfin qu' il ya eu
le transfert de fédération est en cours
c'est grâce à un mécène roumain
qui a qui a fait le mercato pour son
pays
rapportant plein feeding c'est le
discorde
qui jouent contre fabiano
perrine arrive comme ça
je défonce quoi
ça vous n'en voyez des screen
une tête de rapports se faire je voulais
perdre aujourd'hui pour faire chier
caruana c'est vrai qu'il voit des
screens vraiment très grave
je pensais être tranquille aux droits
des candidats sortants a fermé mais même
là en fait il veut poursuivre poursuivre
quoi
tu peux avoir le code d'un pays mais tu
veux pas jouer pour l'équipe nationale
ça aussi ça
pour jouer les candidats encore est vrai
ce serait beau en fait arrivé quand même
encore eh ouais bien sûr quoi
vous avez parlé me critique de niveau
des candidats et qui allait lui rapporte
sireau déjà comme la pire partie des
candidats au niveau
de jeu
non mais bon il est peut-être un petit
peu responsable du jeu de certains quoi
donc pourquoi tu parles quoi
d'après rapporte sud ouest et le round 2
ou 3 à 2 la finale de tournoi peu
importe quoi c'est absolument n'importe
quoi
ça va relativement mal joué
ça lui rapporte quoi richard devenir
humain de l'argent sympa c'est un peu
comme bret est payé pour changer de
nationalité comme un penseur de coutrai
pays il pique certaines games joue
autour de 2300 c'est exagéré non moi je
trouve pas spécialement - je suis 2003
la partie de fil rouge à contre caruana
jaffe
1la català ouais
enfin les deux sont pas là 2003 la main
qui joue bien
oui c'est vrai mais ça la part même je
te la joues je suis pas content quand
même enfin
après will exagère un petit peu mais
certains joueurs sur certaines parties
fillon ne s'était pas pour des raisons
financières alors après peut-être qu'ils
sont bien c'est pas le problème mais
c'était plus qu'ils voulaient partir
d'hier pour pour sa carrière
fréquenté en iran plus tu as besoin de
visa pour partir paris grâce à des
problèmes vas tu peux être bloqués ne
pas jouer on l'a déjà évoqué ils peuvent
pas jouer dans des jarres israéliens
ils doivent ne pas se présenter à la
partie dont tu as des problèmes comme ça
peut-être d'autres je sais pas mais déjà
rien que ça quoi
quinze minutes 1 pour richard alors il
reste que 6 coups mais quand même bof
quand même c'est que hélas pour nous les
oppositions on va peut-être s'y joue
quelques coups très précis tu reste
encore en vie mais peut-être c'est juste
dur je pense être dur
et oui le choix enfin on va y revenir
sur ce choix d'avoir joué oui je veux
pas noir vouloir dans l'esprit c'est
bien après bah c'était pas un bon choix
objectif
sera sûrement c'est sûrement notre grand
format cette partie même si la vidéo
sera quand même assez courte parce que
ça finalement
ouais vas pas des milliers de variantes
a montré au monsieur bien mais ce sera
quand même le grand format je pense
parce que c'est une belle partie quoi
dans le
sait plus à comprendre quoi la dame est
forte
c'est plus stratégique en fait même que
tactique au final face à reposer
beaucoup sûr de la tactique mais
de l'application va être facile de la
pression est très stratégique en fait
alors vous prend 1,7 le problème c'est
qu'il faut des six qui va arriver alors
je sais pas quand c'est maintenant après
tu commences par âge 3 mai
et on fout il lâche une gamme importante
pour la défense
conformité de cette nuit puisque les
parties étaient assez courte
mais là c'est une belle partie
mais oui y'a pas que y'a pas grand chose
après
ouais bon
peut-être que je devrais fiaf pour un
set mais je pensais h3 non
tour g1 pu s'acheter un fou des 6,5
fonds propres
intérêts
il a joué h3
ouais pas mal hein il va il évite le
prem que les canards le fasse mais il
est tout bloqué et on arrête tout à
l'heure il faut aussi être fou machin ou
à 5 da marché puisqu'on avait fait à 5
d'abord mes chaussettes rouges et 5 et
ça désorganise tout faut le trouver mais
bon en même temps avec les north tu dois
le trouver parce que finalement tu as
dame elle au top tu as plus de
perception une pièce qui fait rien cette
fois fuite va dire pas l'un des six
suivants message des cinq ans
a dit comme ça c'est mais moi je vais
bien et met enfin en faisant mais tu
dois subir à cette mauvaise ça et est
donc en soi je me
sens plus humain à cinq guérilleros
temps renault
réfléchit non non ça a joué les cinq la
panda me prend cavaliers 3d qu'on
veut ça peut jouer sous ses trois
carrières de là bas
on aurait quand même les blancs voient
l'or mais bon mais oui se passe pas
grand chose qu ali reza qui a retrouvé
du rythme ouais ça c'est très bien
quoi d'autre
elle met un peu à la cam duda x 4 a bien
joué je crois que si j'avais vu que
c'est le coût de leur dis tu laisses des
5 et je sais pas exactement pourquoi
mais que ça doit les
caruana
bon c'est sûr ce pion plus sale elle
peut durer un moment de paris xi va
s'accrocher rate of en bas il a bien
raison
et du coup une épaule à partie un petit
peu la partie principale de la journée
il a joué le fouet cette quasi à tempo
on avait dit ça c'est logique mais c'est
impressionnant kiloutou tempo et
mais ce que je trouve beau c'est quand
même la différence de niveau entre le
dépôt dans les tournois qui servent à
rien et ce n'est pas là c'est pas du
tout le même niveau ça on va vraiment
l'assainissement en fait non
d'eau suffisent ils sont joués s'en fout
il presserait ne montre aucune idée
montre aucune préparer un que de la
merde
hélas
[Musique]
hélas il est tout le temps debout il
joue vite il joue bien
j'aurais quand même finir la phase aller
avec cinq et demi sur sept ans dans ces
normes
elle a aussi un c pour ça je trouve que
c'est dommage dans le classement elo que
pour aller les joueurs de haut niveau
y'a pas un coefficient quand ça joue
c'est pas normal que ces parties là est
la même importance
je suis d'accord
comme au tennis quand tu gagnes un grand
chelem ou quand il gagne 1 250 c'est pas
pareil quoi
ça sert klose échec tu veux faire une
partie
[Musique]
c'est pareil on fait ça compte autant
que
non il sera pas plus de deux minutes
après les candidats non il part de trop
loin mais mériterait d'être clair nude
mais enfin en fait ça mériterait à vue
au vu de ce tournoi va invoquer les
phases de qualif et c'est que les peaux
et caruana soit clair numéros 2 et 3
mondiaux si ça continue sur sur le
chemin qui est en train de prendre
la phase retour à vue dans la foulée
ouais ouais ça donne
non non c'est pas un truc qui est fait
pour s'arrêter un an c'était juste
l'autre fois qu'ils aient vu ça à cause
de duco vide hormis
les s'enchaînent
browning elle aussi le bât b la guinée
ces points en fait il ya toujours eu une
vie digne il est toujours resté au
dessus 2008 fait très longtemps et très
réguliers juste là il jouait quasiment
plus j'étais en vie enfermée en chine
plus pour le coup il a des problèmes
c'est plus compliqué que pour nous on en
europe 1
il était par ailleurs à des visages un
certain temps dans l'es6 où la vie est
devenue le parent et donc quand tu joues
pas à ton et l'eau ne bouge pas donc
contrairement au tennis vraiment à
quasiment tous en fait si tu joue pas au
tennis tu perds tes points à rogers y
joue pas bientôt il aura plus de points
il sera même plus classe et quoi
voilà donc lui a gardé son classement
donc il y avait un petit peu perdu des
points c'est les matchs joués au
candidat dernière fois mais on rappelle
l'ex particulier pour lui
il a du coup il a rejoué récemment en
chine j'ai pas mal de partis comme des
bons joueurs chinois mais pas des
joueurs de tous âges et les habits
de la chaleur à marcher dessus
voilà ce que je suis lula mais il s'est
plus ou moins sur le nordmann enfin je
veux dire mais elle a peut-être pas
peut-être c'est sûr il joue moins bien
que ce qui lui fait en fait là il est
peut-être un peu haut mais voilà il
faille va pas sombrer ding c'est un
joueur solide
ans ali reza qui pourrait bien baisser
suivant comment ça se passe mais bon
aujourd'hui montre quand même quelques
signes rassurants jeter un oeil sur le
classement voir où on en est on assure
jean biray numéro deux mondial caruana
numéro 3 n'est pas numéro 4 assez loin
d'ailleurs des deux premiers encore
irujo numéro 5
aronian 6 au 7 dommage que ce soit pas
6e
aussi j'aimerais voir saucisses à tanger
maxime je crois qu'il est 9e mais tu as
oui c'est un peu bizarre parce que même
aronian saucisses 7e ils sont pas
qualifiés au candidat maxime non plus
neuf devant rapporte d'un camurat duda
a qu'il en soit
bref c'est l'histoire de qui est pas de
coefficient fait n'est donc 28e des
points aux candidats ou d'en accueillir
candidats ça vaut pas plus que si tu
veux les gagner en ce on devient vision
tu sais pas vous mais après le problème
c'est que s'il y avait des coefficients
quand tu les perds aussi tu perdrais
beaucoup de points contre il m'avait
coûté la vie quoi alors que
disons que en fait j'aurais peut-être
qu'ils aient des bonus en point si tu te
qualifies ouais on dirait plus des bonus
que des maths et malus serait une façon
de conduire pour bien qu'un écrit ce
dernier mais quand la demande n'est pas
juste il a eu le mérite de se qualifier
raja fissures
9e mondiale ouais mais sache non mais
c'est différent parce que là il était à
shirov revenus dans les domaines
châteaux encore une fois à mach foule où
il a pris cher
pas bien pas ben ben
ali mais vraiment pas bien là en fait
ouais non je regarde le classement
intéressant
dans le fourrage de
défendre avec du congé ou non
plus toujours cette façon je m'en veux
un peu de l'âme est trop forte on perd
pas un truc qu'on arrête sa 14ème des
trois noms s agit là encore ça est
d'alger 3 il a fool 3
dans le bras droit d'un coup
sûrement aussi ouais mais bon ça c'est
fini en fait
ça va être une leçon bien jouer bombe
10,2 alors logique ça en fait fait des
coûts force et âmes des deux têtes avec
la tour qui a qu'une casse pour protéger
l'autre
dame d'étroites attaque à trois
têtes il peut essayer de passer à
l'autre tour
tout
[Musique]
boitant et du coup je n 1 7 euro trust
fund c4 après maintenant l'avouent
direct la petite hattie étions trompés
ils partirent d2 ça se voit l'image
qu'elles le sont
je pense ici c'est un grand format on
l'appellera pourquoi mais
il n'ya pas termes récurrents l'avancé
candidat depuis trois éditions de mecs
qui viennent ces mecs qui jouent à
petrov
ouais
c'est pas parce que tu gagnes avec les
noms au noir avec la p3 plus mais qui
essaye de te haïssent casse les dents
ouais ce cas rona à faire en 2002 18
juin qu'il a gagné une partie qui ne
rencontrent cramique est dû à des heures
et des heures oui panique et bien oui
oui non mais je veux dire je m'écrase
bbc il est trop forcer mais il est juste
à tout le tournoi il a joué dans son
match contre magnus il est jamais perdu
avec
aînés pau a pris le flambeau depuis
toujours de petrov
ça a vraiment l'air d'être la partie du
jour 1 pour le moment le reste c'est pas
ça bataille qui arriveront de 5 ou pas
machin ménaka ouais en fait c'est un des
rares à pour la défendre si facilement
genre unis
ont été nombreux à souffrir on va perdre
avec les noirs se situe à un moment et
lui et là il place ses pièces il se
laisse pas faire il te fait te dire un
truc sur un fil peut-être mais ça tient
et
c'est là qu'il est très fort son point
fort il s'est relevé 1 il n'en a rien à
[ __ ] il reste cinq minutes à raison
s'il tombe le verdict est tombé a
rapporté oui mais je ne veux même pas
même par une plus de pression je dois
considérer que la partie est déjà
terminée en fait
ouais
ça va faire un écart un écart de dengue
qui gagne ali riza fait nul j'aurais
déjà trois points de plus
c'est à dire que si fait sept nuls sur
le truc retour
avec sa s ur ça tu veux plus gagné
à 7 sur 7 tu peux parce que tu l'aurais
battu mais
c'est vraiment stratosphérique en fait
c'est stratosphérique
et joue le premier coup qu'on avait vu
les dames détroit a priori il faut 3
d'après fils et ça peut vraiment vite
abandonné 1 parce que si tu va taper à 3
et bk talent pion à il est quasi
n'arrive qu'après tu t'écartes de
l'adversaire entre entre les freins du
roi et le roi noir est complètement
libre complètement en effet et en
sécurité
ne pas se retrouver dans des réseaux
grosse game un
fossile très facile professionnels
concentré 1 et peut une nouvelle fois
sérieux il fait le boulot
ces joueurs qui ont le même même
classement elo que lui avant le début du
tournoi et pourtant on voit quand même
qu'il ya
il ya quand même un écart un gouffre le
sépare frère
et oui mais les ouvertures c'est ce que
je disais pendant le grand jeff tour à
gaza lui caresse c'est qu'en fait si tu
enlèves les ouvertures à des mecs comme
ça enfin c'est comme si tu enlèves la
première balle de service
et ça changerait beaucoup de choses si
surfer les mêmes matches et que tu
interdit à quelqu'un je mets deuxième
balle instantané à quelqu'un t'a pas
deuxième saut j'ai fait de se [ __ ]
nous aurons 15 sujet touche de sérieux
tout le temps en deuxième balle et
seraient pas les mêmes qui gagnera les
matches
enfin je peux me ranger non m'excite
autorise à un hack 1 quel droit la ba
oui oui bien sûr c'est un peu le cas
bucarest entre ceux qui jouent et les
candidats et ceux qui jouaient rien
anaky qui avait pas de premières balles
et d'autres qui en avait une donc ça
change dit quelques petits trucs quoi
enfin
bon comment il peut faire ce qu'il veut
après il faut aussi
on arrive c'est le 40e c'est le dernier
coup pour rapporte
sa paralysie en fait sa position 6 4
attaqué au cas très attaqué à trois est
attaquée a déjà trois en une demi heure
ne peuvent pas bouger la torre un peu va
bouger parce qu'elle doit défendre le
tour donc plus bouger le roi août à tour
de en fait c'est tout ce que tu aventure
ce quelqu'un c'est ce que carlson plus
que les pauvres zhéros ils ont même âge
même à jouer je donnerai catégories
jeunes en fait je crois
donc ils ont à peu près le même âge à
peu près de la même année ces beaux
gosses et rambo tour il est là il
regarde
charogne quoi n'ont pas abandonné
va voulu prendre nul il ya une heure et
demie je te punit comme quoi c'est un
mauvais choix
ça fait trois coups qui checke s'y
rapportent abandonnent ou pas genre en
mode frère à de souffrir
pourquoi t'as pas pris la petite répète
tout à l'heure à temps d'aller voir le
bide
qui est passé un furtivement nom va le
voir revenir
et oui
et continue sa course
jusqu'ici
on va devoir repartir leur sens et leur
odeur ouais ça va être beau quand tu vas
revenir
ça va être beau son retour
je sens à l'échiquier en 2d donc
conséquent ça va jouer
fabriqué en train de jouer
n'empêche ça va lui mettre la pression à
distance à fabien
[Musique]
jusque là sur un trader tu rates quand
même un punto alors pas facile mais tu
rates quand même une occase au blanc
d'un 'put' haute du match a fait
d'autres
en plus il va voir qui est qui s'est
levé il va voir la position de l'époque
après tu peux espérer le dépôt de choc
il peut perdre deux parties dans ce
navire après ouais
tu peux espérer ça quand même notamment
dans son du feu y va fort peut-être qui
le bat en fait
juste ni de retour
et duda elle a pas l'air
particulièrement heureux en trois sets
ok bon
bras je crois savoir d'être logique ça
ça va être joué c'est sûr ça m'a dit je
pouvais pas bouger mon petit peu mais
bon ça coûte 3 koala il regarde genre en
mode
qu'est ce que c'est que ce coup
franc qui a déjà gare en force
et
c'est beau en fait il y en a absolument
rien à [ __ ] un
ont déjà y'a pas tour h2k cause de f3
sur le feuillage 3 sur le cheikh issa
est là toutes les tours alors ouais
je crois j'ai un fort c'est
vous et 3
maintenant j'ai deux tu peux pas
répondre aux jeunes h 1
en fait tu peux pas juste faire sur
l'achat d'un maître roger un fou ces
trois
oui tu vois
ça s'est terminé en fait ce qui va faire
un
bref un peut-être eu aussi des avec le
fossat iii qui arrivait
et daniel 3 qui peut arriver vous
la ds3
3 h
c'est terminé et si tu mets à tours plus
loin tu as déjà
pensé un
jour parce que sa phase finale tour f 2
mais bon tu te rendes un machin
vrai bon ces abandons
je pense m a abandonné il va jouer un
coup et deux abandons
ça peut durer très longtemps
mais encore on en revient à ce choix je
prends une prépa le truc et complique et
a réfléchi une heure
ok je comprends que tu dis je vais à
gagner pour pour avoir encore une chance
mais en fait si tu suscites suicide quoi
bas depuis plus de chances infimes
il a rapporté en réalité il peut rentrer
en roumanie ou en hongrie je sais pas où
il est mais est-ce que tu dois venir
demain attenti tu dis bon écoutez les
gars je jeu fit tout le monde
va rester jusqu'au bout évidemment mais
oui mais mais toujours plus pour rien tu
veux plus pour rien quoi tu es là tu
sais même pas pourquoi en fait
tu décor quoi
cette spéciale parce que fait le monde
va décorer sauf domec
place ici car on a eu beau petit
va encore se battre on va avoir la
niaque ou du coup peut-être tpr et pas
toutes les gares pour un autre truc que
tu es mon côté je gardais pour me
qualifier
ça c'est rien mais là tu es éliminé en
fait alors c'était un contentieux avec
un des deux tu veux vraiment empêché de
se qualifier tu joue à fond preuve que
je n'ai pas d'histoire particulier entre
les gens mais je veux dire mais sinon
on va voir ceux qui ont une
niaque de ouf et ceux qui se disent oui
bon
on va avoir alireza mais on est surtout
venu voir un dépôt qui se balader à bhl
est beau c'est beaumont fab
n'ont réellement très belle performance
de dépôt je suis content qu'on est con
et regarder cette partie en principal
parce que je les trouvais assez
sympathique renault m'a personnellement
c'est une partie agréable à regarder
enfin c'est vrai que ça rend les choses
faciles ce qu'on fera que deux parties à
suivre
peut être les autres ah tiens
non mais on va aller voir ce genre
ah je vois pas de joueur je vois deux
chaises vides
j'ai enfin tu es là tu
voudrais la polaire bien que
je ne connais pas cet homme
je ne fais plus rarement le tournoi
d'après la fidh et leur dire écoutez les
gagnerait sept jours
ont fait un match en huit parties on
enlève un jour pourront faire match en
lui partie entre dépôts et carl et loana
est celui qui gagne va jouer car le
séneçon du bon vin ce serait bon en fait
de changer les règles en cours fin tant
pis
voilà pour le coup n'est poudre pas
d'accord plainte ce qui est devant ouais
mais on dit oui c'est derek c'est comme
ça en fait d'accord je retourne au
ballon à leurs membres
jouer pour la 2e place et carson se
disent oui mais en fait tu vas tu vas
pas être deuxième non plus et vous avez
deux 2e places sont prises en fait
et d'ailleurs si car ça ne saisisse dire
que le tournoi est déjà
d'aller en fait si on savait que carlson
se désister à 100%
tu sais que 1er 2e et qui joueront le
match ensemble
[Musique]
pierre ou là on est sur la partie
différée ou d'ailleurs
bourbon ségalou là j'ai pas trop quoi
dire tune porthus passerait
rien n'est joué on n'est même pas à la
moitié même f-16 et regarde le
classement est enfin là au bout d'un
moment je veux plus répondre
qu'ils se renseignent pas avant de
parler et puis en plus le truc c'est que
les pays bas un des mecs qui est à 50%
au passage
bravo cne popa de carlson quand même nom
mais peut être qu'il a plus qu'à prendre
deux trois trucs sur l'arrimage
fait déjouer
je crois
qu
homme de foi la maison
sam x 3 x 2 h de la charrette
c'est dur et le mettre sur la came pour
le voir abandonner
leurs biens
après il a il a tellement sauver deux
positions perdantes il pourrait déjà
être à -2 dans le toit j'étais foutu
contreur houdoud a honte radjabov ces
contrats doivent y était c'est n'importe
quoi
pas faire flasher dust est fou donc il
est il est en sur régime rapportent il a
cru que sa bonne étoile lui souriait
au
g1 cvo j'aime bien que vous
allez
film thème mais en fait ça rende pas de
la
fiq
en fait juste y clic en fait
j'ai encore deux caveaux qu'ils arrêtent
de cliquer
à fléchir vers 1h45 une petite sieste je
vais dormir
[Musique]
mais il s'en vante pas de vie clics ils
jouent bien bravo hein
après cela nous avec beaucoup de
réussite et compte n'est pas bon pour
moi ya un peu de jalousie quand même
dans tout ce que j'ai pu entendre
non j'suis pas toi conte de fées a
ressenti je pense qu'on n'est pas en
fait
nan mais faut se dire que c'est fini
c'est terminé
je veux dire qu'il a des ddd giga gros
sponsoring à
bon chercher au site mais oui mais c'est
ça mais oui mais bon ça crée de la
jalousie quand tu m'aimais faire graver
des petits fils du champion du monde
quoi donc
bizarrement ils sont entrain bizarrement
ou par exemple ils s'entendent bien car
yakine
ouais gagner à dos
encore que c'est vrai car yakine pendant
longtemps quand il était au top tout le
monde le détester aussi c'est vrai
surtout de la jalousie sauf quand carey
qui ils avaient tous les sponsors avec
l'été motif il le détestait d'enchaîner
pour
défaut trop fort
ben c'est comme partout en fait j'ai
souvent oui en français comme ça mais
oui enfin les américains qui sont pas
trop comme ça
il respecte
pas comme ça mais moins comme ça
bon du coup on va voir fabi ouais s'il
réagit
5 ennemis sur 7,1
crossois saleh
ça peut durer ainsi surtout fabien
salles elle peut être longue mais bon
après longue il reste encore dix neuf
quand même avant la fin du design donc
ils vont devoir je découvre un soir j'ai
des coups quoi
quatre victoires général suffisant pour
gagner les candidats l'année pot avec
une défaite ils l'ont peut remporter le
tournoi catherine s'assemble ouais mais
enfin après peut-être ces candidats va
faire faire plus un coût plus 6 en fait
juste c'est tellement faible autour un
faible par rapport mais plus personne ne
joue rien face à ce qu'on disait donc
avoir des motivés parce que des joueurs
qui jouent pour se qualifier
non c'est un club me sur 7 c'est
réellement l'impression et puisque s'il
fait trois points et demi sera on avait
dix huit et demi au début et là il sera
neuf
et ce serait pas si c'est pas sûr qui
gagne 1,9 en fait
des chances bonne chance
marrant
ouest a fait nul dans ma mère de baffes
hélas échappé qu'un point d'avancé après
après pour lui rennes c'est fini ce
qu'il à l'affrontement direct et puis ce
n'est pas facile louisiane thermique un
demi point et oui vaut mieux pour
carbone qui en fait partie
est ce que ces balles apparemment
aujourd'hui après je sais pas quand ils
ont une fois les blancs et les noirs
respectivement
fabi 4,3 et les pauvres 4-3 dans le sens
vu que trois blancs des popotes doublons
et blanc contre fier roubles encontre
duda vie de gains et jacques et marie
combs dingila
impressionnant qu'elle
est bon aujourd'hui séraphin c'est un
portier lui donne non parce qu'il allait
la chercher derrière mais rapporte qui
fait quand même un choix
même c'est bizarre en fait c'est qui les
rend plus fort en fait parce que quand
tu joues des salaires hyper facile
fréquenté facile contre tout le monde
j'ai toujours in fine
on joue bien c'est facile en fait ben
non mais c'est parce que c'est parce
qu'ils jouent mais que c'est facile mais
je veux dire justement le choix
de pouvoir clore les débats faire nul je
vois que tu t'es pris près pâte a
réfléchi une heure
tu souffles quoi nous on aurait fait nul
sans réfléchir
et on aurait pris les petits points elo
ah bah oui oh bah nous lasser insérant
un charroi j'ai un papa moi monsieur
c'est au genre droit de se retirer du
tournoi est malheureusement non
non
sauf raisons de santé ou quoi je veux
dire va te dire ça me saoule jack
ça t'as pas le roi
est là pour quoi il pouvait pas prendre
le
2e tour d2 du club
[Musique]
alors ça c'est doux da contre nac a
essayé de faire un bep prendra mais les
cavaliers vers 5 1 mais bon c'est un peu
moins grave que oui mais ça reste quand
même
nul mais tu as quand même envie de la
jouer un petit peu abba va toujours maso
à mon avis là
dans mon époque et qui est assez
incroyable
c'est beau ce qu'il est en train de
faire
belles ressources mentales un poids
le joueur russe
ce que dit ni va réussir à mettre la
pression à ali reza ou inversement on se
perd pas
dans le closing met la pression
joue plus rien là nul de salon pour les
concerts pas vraiment ça pas le droit
faut jouer en 40 pouces
le calice jusqu'à la lie gouët c'est
terrible pour eux
ça c'est à regret que je déteste ouais
mais elle est compréhensible au sien il
ya eu trop de nuls arrangé
en fait ouais de deux choses l'une où
fait dans tous les tournois exhibitions
là je comprends heureusement la règle tu
payes des joueurs pour venir et odom un
spectacle donc tu leur dis je 40 couches
avec vos pieds vous avez fait un jeu ont
fait jeter un beau surtout vertueux
enfin tu peux faire ce que tu en fait
après le joueur accepte de jouer il joue
là en fait c'est juste du genre qui
mérite d'être là messieurs le faire du
fond d'une en fait si tu leur fais pas
une faveur d'être ici tu leur offre rien
en fait ils sont venus chercher leur
place dont qui gère le tournoi que nous
envie de le gérer donc pour moi en fait
c'est
donc la plupart des tournois je leur
imposera de jouer parce que j'ai pas un
devoir des nuls à payer des mecs à venir
l'empiré billets d'avion les machins
lherminez ray et puis que ça joue pas
mais
en fait je leur ferai rien qu'en fait ça
ces fonds là parce qu'ils méritent
d'être là s'il veut le faire nul
bareille font ce qu'ils veulent quoi bah
oui enfin c'est pourquoi je serais pour
les éliminer si si ça joue plus rien bah
ça pourquoi pas aussi en fait
mais tant pis quand on voit après
on va pas changer des formats
ce soit des formats de match ou pouvoir
y avoir comme au golf un cut
si t'as pas tant après la phase aller tu
dégages et puis bah là peut-être étape à
50 jours du dégagement occasion pour une
part sauf peut-être n'a qu'à faire
annuler les deux autres îles fidji et
expliquent comme ça sur la fin bah je
sais pas en fait ça c'est on n'a jamais
posé chez avec le 4 mai finalement même
dans les open je trouve c'est pas une
mauvaise chose
le sermon galère de jouer quand t'as
plus envie que tu joues pour rien que tu
traînes sa peine durant même fin tu te
dégoûte du jeu en fait
donc grande pour les joueurs c'est une
avancée en fait c'est horriblement pas
que pour le public un jeu dire
non est complètement et puis pour ceux
qui kiffent vraiment joué dans les open
battu leurs familles de consolante un
truc bonjour entre eux ils s'amusent et
puis voilà
problème blonde walk of passion du jeu
précis ronde ou peu importe tant pis un
premier problème après la le puissance
comme le tableau
à
donc à lire et 5 contre une ding
ça a l'air de bien tout liquide et je
sens la petite nuit où il se serait rien
passé de la partie quand un homme comme
on aimerait
way le plus simple si tu fais des
matches et point barre avec comme dit à
zelda ça c'est tellement logique en fait
que
quelques temps golf bas
at ça tue
les parcours au golf on te dit tu dois
le faire en trois coups en machin etc
issus des passes ta puce un plus haut
depuis ce machin et le cut en fait c'est
que après la première journée s'est
décidé à l'avant je pense que six
joueurs sont tous ceux qui sont à plus
de jeux pas +3 +10 plus ça peu importe
quoi illuminer marchés passés décidé à
l'avancé ou si tu prends classement et
que tu gardes plus que les 20 premiers
ou je sais pas quoi je pas trop experts
des dérogatoire golf mais en gros c'est
ça le principe c'est que ce kit façon
sans à l'ouest et ont plus aucune chance
bas c'est fini
tu prends le classement ok c'est pas
définies elles avancent le nombre de
placements t'enlève la moitié a mis ça
dégage non mais au fait pourquoi pas eh
bien quoi ça dégage
je vais manger un petit truc je reviens
vas-y bonhommes
d'anges de la salade
fruits
salades de fruits
notre ami digne d'une belgique à quatre
attaques la dame qui doit rester sur
cette cinquième manger pour continuer à
défendre l'option donc qu'est ce qu'il
ya comme choix c'est mg5 c'est mc5 ouais
les deux doivent très bien aller et
après on va en échange ici des relations
un peu isolés ici va se dessiner dams et
5 été choisi par hasard
bouffe
reprendre
donc voilà un pion un peu isolé mais qui
passent en même temps qui apprend des
ressources chez les blancs et puis en
contrepartie tu peux appeler visé par là
bas donc
le faire
du coup car le syndrome ans son titre
quelqu'un d'autre casa guen alors je
sais pas ça un soutien on sait ce qu'il
avait annoncé dans une interview mais ça
n'engage à rien
il l'a dit bon il va le faire ou pas
je
sais son pouce à lui de voir je sais pas
la seule raison pour s'agissant du nom
mais
[Musique]
je pense que c'est quand même une énorme
préparation au championnat du monde ça
prend beaucoup d'énergie
peut-être pour les nerfs c'est dur ou
quoi et que en gros ils allaient
recevoir déjà jouer un peu contre tout
le monde n'a rien à prouver
et j'imagine c'est assez raison en fait
un
effet boeuf peut défendre sa position
mais on va les voir
alors de base moi je pense que oui il
peut défendre mais alors je pas quelques
âmes sein de la gamme 4 il est là
radjabov
donc
je pour un job à oui c'est qu'il a
besoin de moi
et ça peut durer longtemps
le point pour respirer ce qui est
proposé aux données finales
tenable mais évidemment fabi il veut
peut-être juste fait un coucou me tour
des 1 tour 17 évidemment pression là bas
un peu là-bas donc ça arrangerait les
nains un peu kitur s'en aille il va
devoir faire une longue défense c'est
pas une partie marrante alger pour
radjabov mais
je veux dire en soi c'est pas perdant sa
position
il ya deux pions doublé car on savait
mais comme on disait tout à l'heure si
un an tu attaques ce pion et tu le
manges ou même tu te force à avancer ça
va donner une case d'accès ici que tu
aurais pas vu c'est si on n'existait pas
en fait
tu peux aussi avoir des plans gkf 4 g4
g5 et ici et un jour ton pions en double
hélice échanges place un groupe plus
donc en fait vaut mieux l'avoir que ne
pas l'avoir 60 il faut pas le
sous-estimer ce truc en plus évidemment
il sera en plus ici c'est un plus gros
avantage
mais mais il n'est pas anodin le panneau
de
bonbons fille rousse est assez égale
retourner voir mais là on peut s'arrêter
ici parce que pour l'intérêt du tournoi
scam là que ça se joue plus qu'ailleurs
et donc
l'info du jour c'est que le dépôt a déjà
gagné les nominés express avec les noirs
contre
contreras porte
en fait on peut seront voir la partie si
vous voulez rapidos en fait n'est prouvé
les noirs il ajouta petrov
up du classique
il rapporte
à jouer ça mais pourquoi cette île et
prendre des cette dame prend d'emprunt
vite fois je crois tempo menace d'un
projet de match puis on prend un échec
et là ça peut répéter les coups vous
faites là c'est rapporte ci a le choix
entre faire nulle où vous essayez de
gagner parce que bon voilà il ya une
tour de plus il se dit peut-être que je
sais pas et il fait ça je n'ai pas le
connaître et jusqu'où
faire échec à revenir et l'a à nouveau
il peut faire nul mais il n'en joue bien
paf nam 17 et donc c'était tout l'idée
d'amender noire sexy liban refuse la
nulle cette dame ici en fait elle bloque
l'autre elle prend ces casses de fuite
juste enlever son cabinet pour gagner la
dame et
voilà mais il rapporte à donner la dame
en disant ok j'ai de l'eau tour mais
laurent un peu faible et ils pourront
faire juste remis de la phase après will
a ramené ses pièces vers le roi il a
créé les problèmes des champions qui
arrive
et petit à petit la dame qui s'engouffre
de fou qui sera même et il a défoncé
voilà à vendre on parce que la suite ces
dames ici en fait tu mais il faut pour
couvrir bas soyaux ramat soit bas le
pion ou madame bon bonne partie de dépôt
rapport dans facialement à trop jouer
avec le feu a mal jugé il a voulu jouer
pour le gain une position trop
dangereuse a dû probablement se
contenter de de répéter mais c'est
toujours facile à dire après et donc
voilà allez on peut retourner
chez fabi
stade analyse express à bari
bassem pas il a duré capa et merci à
nassim 1% abonnement
et
du coup vraiment mais là donc on va voir
à ce que je joue ce que j'aurais déjà
beaufissimes et que je vous dise averti
qu'il va durer ça va être une longue
france entre guillemets jeu vers les
noirs vont devoir défendre longtemps
c'est pas si simple
je voudrais c'est fini ben non pas
encore mais ça tend vers la nulle ou
touré 8 joué par radja team et donc sa
tour sur cette colonne qui une pression
sur le fou évidemment ina souffrance et
3 ont peut-être un coup comme f3 pour
gbagbo tempo pour bien défendre se fout
bien l'encré d'impression et ours est
donc pour défendre la cia manger vrai
que c'est pas bête ça évite des entrées
de tours en 17 pour le moment donc voilà
on peut faire un détour voir ce qui se
passe ailleurs jarre chez ding contre
ali reza les voilà à l'image et la
position
donc tu les échanges s'ils sont passés
en bessin quand je rappelle la position
était comme ça après j'ai quatre daims
bougez vous ouf et
aïe s'attend vraiment vers la nul ça en
fait il ya carrément plus trop de pièces
dont une paire de tours qui peut
disparaître sur le long de la colonne
des
il va y attaquer ses pions avec les
blancs mais ils n'ont pu défendre
facilement donc je pense que ça va pas
trop mal et on peut y aller voir cette
machine bah si
c'est la silla mettre un peu la pression
pas bon on verra en gros l'idée des
blancs c'est d'avoir un cavalier contre
ce fou qui pas terrible et de se dire ok
par manca deschamps je pense très
mauvaise idée de la part du nord prendre
avec le cavalier leroy qui va concerner
sur les cases noires s'il vient ici
c'est gagné alors bien sûr les endroits
ont essayé d'empêcher
peut-être des dalles et par là bas le
kali qui va naviguer après train de
coups par g5 un coût par là et
travailler la position a priori nakaa
pas intérêt à échanger peut-être gardé
sa tour active mettre une pression là où
je sais pas vous calculez le fou à voile
a beau avoir l'air très mauvaise idée
fond comme des pions importants
donc tour de apprends moi me tourner
peut-être pour attaquer ça
qu'ils aillent aux 6 et puis je sais pas
ce qui ramène le roi s'il est fou 17 on
verra mais donc aujourd'hui on en est là
ces six tours de jouer mais on n a qu à
voir refuser l'échangé faire ça ou aller
en quelque part
alors ce petit robin c'était pas mal je
fais pancetta
un peu j'ai repris un peu de peine à
quoi mais j'avais faim tout d'un coup
on met un peu de décence dans le moteur
bah ça donne faim c'est parti en fait
à gaza a fait un nul en maths façon il
peut être est ce qu'on
disait depuis un moment que la voilà
ouais qu'est-ce que tu en vivre au maroc
vive revenant je repars maroc
jusqu'en france non union européenne
états unis je pense canada mais gentil
je sais pas c'est potentiellement
faisable mais il faut demander
y a pas de face à être ça va être
caruana la partie vraiment intéressante
quoi
est ce jour ont refait un stage au maroc
on viendra cas avec du matos
ouais
jérémy alireza en fait
ce qu'ils vont faire nul
ouais mais en fait c'est ali reza
peut-être là il a il a joué plus solide
plus tranquille
il faut
c'était déjà mieux que les autres jours
même si dans le temps ou quoi il ya eu
quelques petits trucs un peu bizarres au
moins il a
il a fait une bonne partie aujourd'hui
montrent
pas de prise de tête trompe qui
nulle et du coup il restera deux parties
et surtout
caronna radjabov important pour le
classement
assez la partie importante on fait alors
garde pour balla parce que c'est là
qu'on veut voir la fin et que ça peut
être traîné à priori mais on sait jamais
pas un peu trop chauffer avec les noirs
ils s'échauffent niveau mais bon appelé
ils étaient dominés simplement c'est
peut-être juste celle contre caruana oui
c'est chauffé la précédente en fait
oui il faut accepter deux nuls parce que
si nul quoi
diniz je tâte juin la finale
il peut rien à jouer mais pourquoi pas
citoyenne b5 après tu peux travailler
juste pour faire chier
par tout cas si tu spot final c'est pas
le truc de pro forte ton adversaire avec
lataste évolution là et unis montre sans
moi je ne suis rien un peu tourner en
rond et puis tu gardes bien
ce que peut-être que là
ya un coût de sa tour but qui est dit
s'inquiéter qu'est
ce que t'en rends b5 échange 2,3 à
montceau
et s'il ya plus de cavaliers
[Musique]
qui essaient de ici forcément cette
inversion pour les joueurs pros que ça
peut faire caler ses trois mais
veut pas faire qu'il y ait des 5-6
bizarre ça te donne ce type tu as envie
de te dire tient peut-être aussi un truc
après bon j'ai à dire que normalement ça
devrait aller mais bon qui sait à trois
ils montent plus vite en jeu et de
changer de nom pour orages et vite tu
peut-être grillé les cinq grands des
bons cas j'en sais rien je
vais pas dire faut faire gaffe mais
mais pas loin quand même affaire qui les
dessins et a raté le truc très clean
non mais tu la joues
ou si on va voir famille
importants ont pu reviendra voir un peu
quand est ce que tu as raison
on va avoir le famille
il est bien quand même 1 13 buts contre
18 h 15 coups
on sait quand aura lieu le prochain
championnat du monde je crois que c'est
mars incessants 7 mars mais après
j'en suis pas sûr et
je crois qu'à pas de lui annoncer encore
du vieux dans ce prix de games et ça
comme ça et
sorte une deuxième saison d'ailleurs je
pense à mon
art est attendu un bon succès dans la
première sur d'anciennes deuxième je
peux pas dire ça serait une bonne saison
mais financièrement ce serait une bonne
saison
on sait jamais hein j'avais la bonne
surprise
le regarde the boys et quand même je
dirais c'est quand même de mieux en
mieux
je passe toujours mieux me soit race
bien ça reste correct
mais bon je crois qu'ils avaient des bd
enfin des comics oui mais ça se prépare
ouais mais tu es un peu d'un truc sur
quoi s'appuyer sur le caractère des
personnages ma chère tu pouvais pas trop
partir en vrille quoi
meiway le dernier épisode je sais pas
pourquoi tout le monde a vraiment
tellement adoré non il est pas mal mais
bon ou non mais pas mieux que le reste
c'est bien mais c'est pas
le de m regardez le saison debré
l'académique moi je connais pas c'est
quoi c'est un manga un animé non non ce
ferry série sa 3ème saison c'est un peu
décalé ce je bois je trouve ça pas mal
frêche c'est pas un petit vieux parti
renvoyer
saison 1 j'ai trouvé mieux que la 2d
jamais là de se regarder crème bien donc
bon on va voir il ya une b2 moi les
miens kesha est parfaite mais ça mais ça
faisait quelque chose dans les
bons surtout reçoit sympathique on verra
son trois sorties way et sortir au mieux
ça va chauffer j'ai pas vu je peux
abonnés au truc j'ai pas dis ce n'est
déjà pas une abonnée à tout les trucs
qui existe sinon autant vente va
chauffer à mais en plus de boys qui est
bien c'est que ça avec prime donc c est
fin et amazon prime l'enquêté sont sur
twitter ou quoi tu vas forcément plus ou
moins et du coup c'est gratuit gratuit
et c'est pas très cher dans le truc et
on dit qu'il est mort le 2 1 ça ça ne
m'intéressait oui tu regardes encore moi
j'ai lâché ah beh oblige jusqu'au bout
je regardais
il est vrai que j'ai adoré le son une
plus que le reste est un peu d'un chèque
à être davantage de life pour
regarder
on a quelques on au 25e
ouais m'enfin je découvre vite que c'est
pas une vision simple tu vois il n'y a
plus trop de pièces mais
alors que walking dead gérard d
non mais j'ai fait j'ai un peu de mal à
lâcher les séries alors des fois quand
c'est vraiment trop naze j'en peux plus
quoi mais
les résas c'est fini non mais
comme la pollution est vraiment égal on
se met sur la tête du tournoi parce que
c'est une partie vraiment importante ça
la wii
pour kavanagh faut gagner
ce que ton équipe de foot
pétrole je le serai pas c'est beau mais
valeurs nationales je changerai pas pour
la vie
pour moi quand des supporters c'est pas
la carte que quand ça va bien
ça calcule côté rajhi
à point c'est que c'est une position
pleine imtu
est à aucun set up qui te fait nul tout
de suite parti pour durer et pour
des problèmes pendant un moment quoi
peut-être un plan pour les blancs
seraient même à un moment de faire à
troyes b 4 cap des cinq à les enlever ce
cavalier affaiblir bessette avec un
client c'est 5 par exemple
et petit à petit avant cela bas puis une
tentation à ce 7e enfin
pense qu'il accable belle chance de
gagner notre ami karl mannheim signe
une très bonne position
n'avancez pas gagnant radiographie il
défend avec l'opiniâtreté dans ce
tournoi il est encore en dessous long
terme au niveau je trouve mais manille -
fort wayne on me lâche pas en fait il
est bien dans l'attitude quoi il aurait
pu battre apporte un quand même
malheureusement pour lui
complexe
et
puis c'est lui qui est sous pression
parce que c'est lui qui est en chasse
patate 1 1 on espère qu'elle ait pas
patate la chasse pour lui on sent
donc des poursuivants non mais il est
seul
quoi oui on se fait un effort solitaire
n'y a pas deux joueurs pour
l'accompagner pour le ramener quoi vous
serez vous qu'il ya un équipier qui est
naka qui se sacrifient quoi
on peut plus garder grande et noble non
non mais là aujourd'hui c'était
tant mieux
mais c'était déjà mort mais je dirais
même si fait nul qui est pas un mauvais
résultat mais combinée à la victoire de
données bosser encore rené peau
elle a vraiment trois points de retard
fin c'est impossible
oui mais surtout qu'il ya du monde au
mieux même s'il n'est pose même pas
faire n'importe quoi ta caruana qui a
quand même une avance conséquente
il n'y a pas de raison que les banques
se mettent à faire n'importe quoi du
jour au lendemain et dans il est dans
son tournoi ils jouent bien donc
verra s'ils réussissent à la terre mais
je pense qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
gars en blanc dans leur âge
la partie peut durer
voilà
bah en fait il va se passer un truc je
vous 40e coup
s'est pas accélérée mauvaise défense ou
fabi qui l'intriguent imprécis et qui
laissent là nul se rapprocher il ya chez
un peu son avantage ou quoi je sais pas
presque garder la pression en l'état on
était bien quoi
le roi est monté webb à leurs soeurs
active et ne reverser 5
assez rare bien nul
mais il va lui jouer parce qu'on veut on
paraît que mila et s'est montré fébrile
très franchement avec les north a pas de
danger l'un
des limites et blanc tu vas faire face
un grand
ses limites et blanc qui est un peu
abusé sur les derniers
tu fais quoi on retrouvera des quatre
années
regardez un peu ce si le roi a bien
versé cinq cas annoncés un peu ton pions
b éloigné machin
vraiment exagéré mais
peut-être juste reculé à tour en fait on
s'assurera c5 qui colle un échec et puis
tu reviens c'est plus simple
alors il s'est activé une affiliée des 4
c'est juste la façon
et au 29e coup quand on regarde avec
vois la tour 2 dakar faisait les changes
logique caillou six
macaques qui va réussir à la tenir il va
rester à 50% d'un cas nous y
décrocher mais il fait son temps d'un
cas
aujourd'hui mais il a bien tenu une
position que je ne mets pas un
stratégiquement déjà expliqué mais il a
bien su trouver le nazisme il fallait
dans la position pour la tenir
wen voyez décrocher mais qui est
décroché deux par les résultats
extraordinaires de ses adversaires
directs il peut juste s'en vouloir de la
partie contre l'epo qui valait h4 machin
oui il ya eu des quatre pieds des deux a
changé beaucoup de choses puisqu'il bat
est un adversaire direct ouais donc
résistance du streamer ray
mais mérite sa place en et poya eux
n'est pas la cas il n'y a pas de doute
ans
dans le groupe des battus c'est un des
plus forts m'appellera ce groupe le
groupe n'a qu'à
vrai qu'il ya un petit resserrement à
50% qui fût ce un peu collaboré
peut-être le seul à 50% mais c'est pour
ça que j malheureusement il est seul
ouais esseulé au sida il prend le vent
grandement réf ce très beau qui
l'attendent oui bon je vais faire
quelques petites minutes je vais
attendre autour d'eux joue là on va se
mettre à deux comme un fou
déjà fait un demi point d'avancé sur
caruana il reste est pas rien
même s'il a un point mais il s'est mis
bien il y fait une super phase aller et
comment de la date où
toutes les espérances
karaoké dans le peloton
c'est le tour de france qui débute le
1er challenge
il devient cette année le tracé où
aucune idée
est ce que je sais c'est que tous les
ans je prends le 11 cycling manager a
battu sera là on pourra peut-être le
faire peut-être pas le temps qu'on fasse
ça démarre là qu'on étudie un peu on en
voit gaudu et ou
à la place des résumés de corne et
autres
le soir matin auprès live live voiture
il vous intéresse mais quand des taux il
peut plus faire après ou non s'il peut
fermer fin tant pis viré pour
le tour de france dommage que vers juin
aujourd'hui c'est quand il ya eu
120 airbus va durer les miettes en
france il adore le vélo d'ailleurs
toutes les classiques et où ils adorent
georges jouent pas le jeu en fait
jusqu'à 8 7 pour le truc pour l'émission
de mathieu qui est qui était très
qualitatif pour la peine
je veux savoir 14 saab
c'est du boulot ça et pendant que
j'étais là je pense qu'on avait déjà eu
cinq ou six avant l'émission je pense
que pour l'émission il ya huit ou neuf
top quoi
ouais alors que c'est du boulot c'est
bien expliqué ça permet de
c'est pas très motivant quoi on va dire
ça comme ça
prendre du vélo à la belote
enfin pas vraiment là parce que c'est
pas principe abstrait je vais pas lâcher
un truc mais c'est gentil quand c'est
gentil quand même oui
et ça compte pas spécialement
je me suis bien non non j'en ai parlé
hier mais c'est juste que je pense c'est
la dernière dernier tour mais on fera un
truc comme ça assez
à
faut mieux le faire après les parties
les gens se plus après mais quand on le
fait avant
maillot jaune thibaut pinot vous l'aurez
vu ici en premier bain peut-être pour
pour notre tour de france alors dit
propose un truc intéressant en fait
manque la tour ans et 7,5 m pour moi
c'est tout bêtement en fait qu'ils aient
b4 18 et a3 et
le truc peut-être
et en d3 tu forces vous prend ses trois
balles assez content voix
[Musique]
bac il faut arrêter ici bas faites moi
je paye quoi
ça vaille pas mais enfin je suis pas
mère teresa qua
non à tort c'est cette
force 5 2 3 qui est vrai dans ça a l'air
fort en vrai
ça a l'air fort
je redoute a fait nul ah ouais ouais ils
ont fait nul
on n'a qu'à partir son petit sac voyez
content
il a jamais pu espérer mieux dans la
partie n'a kameni noir c'est correct
firoud qu'est ce qui s'est passé il y
aura des six tours b un recul de 5 et 6
7 qui est b quatre tours a dit
on va rester sur
ce que je pense pas que ouais ouais
ok donc dès demain soir
au quai vauban voir le tandem un temps
fou contre tours cavaliers c'est plus
fort et tu t'en fous mais faut voir
alors peut-être en d3 chats préfèrent
l'option b 2 quoi si on vous sait pas
fait tourner trois le bras long et
j'avais peur d'un cavalier bekkat way
3 du coût est attaqué
et une belle cadence et 4 ont planté
deux cavaliers ou quoi c'est pas faire
ses preuves
c'est loin d'être fait en fait
je te sens un peu ensuite bon bon bon
bon port ce qui se passe dans cette
partie en voiture et de te dire
[Musique]
favilla qui est peut-être en train d' un
peu raté son truc comme nous a mal
habitué
c'est un jouet défend
m6 ok tout bloquer
salaires la ramaz chances acsé nul quand
même bon on va dire un plan pour les
blancs possibles s'avéreront h5 garder
un f4 dans le futur mais pour les
plantes et le ranger six là bas